this is jocko podcast number 317 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening all right
the
marine corps
specifically the marine corps institute
has
well they seem to do this on a regular
basis they
put out manuals with
with some incredible insight
about leadership
about human nature
about combat
and it's not just about combat
it's not just about combat at all
the things that they put out
apply directly to business and to life
in general and i'm going to read some
excerpts today
from a manual that was actually designed
for remote learning and i think these
days when we think of remote learning we
think of zoom
calls sure this is old school remote
learning
where you'd get a book read a book read
a section learn about something take
tests inside the sections
it's a
it's one of those it's a remote learning
old school remote learning where you'd
get a book a manual fill in answers read
sections
this particular class
is called infantry squad leader
combat leadership and
i'm just going to review some of the
texts if you go online there's you can
go online and get this manual and
there's questions and there's quizzes
and there's
it's a full-on course
but the text that's in it
it's a
very
well-written
text and addresses things that
apply to everything that everyone does
all the time every day stuff stuff we
all have to contend with
so
here we go
infantry squad leader
from the marine corps institute
combat leadership
it starts off with a little cover letter
from the director of the marine corps
institute
this the subject course provides
instruction for all marine ncos on the
conditions of combat and how they can
begin to prepare their marines for
combat now if you aren't a marine
and you're a business leader or you're a
football coach
or you're a parent in a family i think
you're going to see this applies to you
too
hundred percent
and i knew you and i can throw around
100 from time to time just sort of
a little bit much
but i'm telling you this one right here
so it starts off and this is the way
they this is what i like about the
marine corps thinks through some stuff
here's something they thought through it
starts off with this congratulations
on your enrollment in a distance
education course from the distance
learning and technologies department of
the marine corps institute since 1920
the marine corps institute has been
helping tens of thousands of
hard-charging marines like you
improve their technical job performance
skills through distance learning by
enrolling in this course you have shown
a desire to improve the skills you have
and master new skills to enhance your
job performance
they're building you up just as you read
this you're getting in the game
here's your personal character it
actually is going to tell you what your
personal characteristics are
you are properly motivated you have made
a positive decision to get training on
your own self-motivation is perhaps the
most important force in learning or
achieving anything doing whatever is
necessary to learn is motivation you
have it
that's a good tactic by the way you seek
to improve yourself now again does this
apply to just marines in combat
how many human beings are looking to
improve themselves everyone
you seek to improve yourself you are
enrolled to improve those skills you
already possess and learn new skills
when you improve yourself you improve
the core
you have the initiative to act by acting
on your own you have shown you are a
self-starter willing to reach out for
opportunities to learn and grow these
are like the most positive attributes
they can put on a human being and
they're just throwing them
how about this one you accept challenges
you have self-confidence and believe in
your ability to acquire knowledge and
skills you have the self-confidence to
set goals and the ability to achieve
them enabling you to meet every
challenge
you are able to set and accomplish
practical goals you are willing to
commit time effort and the resources
necessary to set and accomplish your
goals these professional traits will
help you successfully complete
this distance learning course i was
actually thinking we were going to go
into like a whole another realm of
living
but it is gonna help us with this
distance learning course as well
uh starts off a little section called
characteristics of combat every marine
is a war you're a potential combat
leader
you may be in combat tomorrow regardless
of how well your unit is trained you
must harden yourself for your first
action you do not need to experience
combat in order to understand the
essential requirements for leading your
marines in combat however it's
fundamental it is your fundamental
responsibility to physically and
mentally prepare yourself and your
marines for battle
now
are we just talking about marines what
about life
what about life you may be in a hard
situation
tomorrow that's what's going on so you
got to prepare for that
so this starts off with an excerpt this
is probably the longest excerpt that i'm
going to read
it's
from
a book called the forgotten soldier by
guy ser
it's a book that we actually haven't
covered on this podcast i'll go into a
little bit of why that is but here we go
we had just witnessed
two or three major assaults
from the screams of anguish to our left
we concluded that a great many of our
men had been killed we had emptied five
magazines and were warming our fingers
on the hot metal of the machine gun
our sixth and last magazine had been
attached and we were anxiously waiting
for fresh supplies the night was
continuously lit by the explosions of
thousands of russian shells which made
movement extremely difficult our
trenches which in any case were not deep
enough extended only to certain
positions
the others had to be reached by leaps
and bounds alternating with plunges to
the ground and writhing on our stomachs
across dozens of yards of snow mixed
with chunks of frozen earth
from time to time we could see four
figures moving toward us jumping from
crater to crater carrying shells for our
50 millimeter mortar and magazines for
the spandau
they were still about 40 yards away when
their shadowy mass was surrounded by a
flash of white light
we never heard any cries
a few minutes later i was sent out to
crawl to the point of impact the
sergeant ordered me to bring back at
least two magazines
i had just arrived at my destination
when i heard the russian assault cry
followed by shower of grenades and
mortar shells
the ground shook beneath me in a manner
which defied all predictions
i felt like a pee inside a fierce
ferociously beaten drum
i was lying flat on the ground among the
bodies of comrades killed only a few
minutes before unable to see any of the
supplies i'd been sent to fetch
then i heard the sound of a tank
the darkness all around me was broken by
streaks of light and large pink and
yellow explosions
in a momentary beam from some headlight
i could see a small sign marked s-157
i opened my mouth wide as prescribed
because i could hardly breathe and lay
where i was frantically groping for
something to hang on to in the
diabolical setting where horizontal and
vertical alternated to the rhythm of the
lights which slashed the darkness
i thought that i could recognize the
uproar
the crackle of the weapon i had operated
with weiner before
i had only left a moment ago and felt
that my sanity might be close to
collapse
i could see no escape from my situation
and lay glued to the ground with my head
down like a trust animal
waiting for the butcher's axe
so it goes on a little bit further with
this
with this section which is out of that
book the forgotten soldier and we
haven't covered that book on the
on that podcast the forgotten soldier
we probably will at some point there's
some
disputes about the veracity of the book
and
the author i think i was just reading a
little bit more about this last night
the author
guy said
he there's some important details that
he misses that he just gets it wrong
one of them is there's some patch that
they had in this in this unit
and it was this highly regarded patch
and he talks about how they sewed it
onto their
right sleeve or left sleeve or something
like that and
people that were in that unit said no
way would any
buddy that was in that unit ever make a
mistake about where to sew that patch on
that's
that's one of the types of things or
there's certain weapons that he talks
about that
weren't there he talks about an aircraft
that didn't exist at this time so
there's some things in there that
there's some details that were wrong and
some of the veterans that fought
fought in the same battles as him have
called them out and said this guy's not
telling the truth about some stuff and
then there's other veterans that
talk about the battles or that he writes
about and say hey the only way he would
know this stuff is if he was there
so
and here's the thing memory is not
accurate and people's memories aren't
accurate and certainly people's memory
about intense combat operations isn't
accurate
and he eventually made a statement about
that he kind of said that said hey if
you want to know the historical details
go ask a general that was
actually i'm about to go off a little
bit he doesn't say that
he says go ask a military historian go
ask a general because that's what they
do i didn't want to do that my book is
about the emotions of a combat soldier
but the reason they put this in here
is to get
a good account of the chaos and mayhem
and fear inside of combat and then you
roll right into
this section here which is called fear
of combat
it starts off with this we have all
experienced fear in combat fear can
dominate the situation unless you and
your marines can control it
extreme fear brings out your instinct
for self-preservation
survival drive
survival is a very strong drive which
generally will be a priority concern to
any marine
as i was reading this and again i'm
reading these things in the context of
life
and
fear is something that people contend
with every single day and it's on all
kinds of different levels
but
whether it's fear of presenting in front
of a client
whether it's fear of asking for a raise
whether it's fear of confronting some
situation
whether it's fear of going to a jujitsu
class for the first time like there's
all kinds of
fears that people face on a daily basis
and here's some good information that
yes it'll help you if you're a combat
marine but also help you if you're a
human
specific sources of fear peacetime
training may not prepare your marines
for the reality that combat is often a
matter of kill or be killed some of the
specific sources of fear in combat are
possibility of being killed wounded or
captured fear of killing noise and
sights of combat apprehensive that you
might not measure up as a marine under
fire and the last one is fatigue
so possibility of being killed wounded
or captured this is a natural source of
fear and always we will be present in
your marines
it may lead your marines to run away
from battle or do irrational things in
battle there is no sure way to know
which marine may be subject to such an
extreme reaction to fear to this fear
until you get into combat
fear of killing this is not uncommon our
society is a peaceful one by nature we
are raised to respect the rights of all
human beings and have to
and to have respect for life
to forget these facts is to ignore the
reality
of our culture
another one is the noise and sights of
combat these elements have a traumatic
shocking impact on the senses this
causes confusion and a sense of chaos
that can become particularly unnerving
no peacetime training can completely
prepare you and your marines for the
carnage and emotional impact of combat
to ignore this aspect of combat is to
create a lack of understanding
that could prove totally debilitating to
your marines one thing i like about this
is it's
no no punches are pulled
hey guess what
the carnage and emotional impact of
combat
are you're not going to be able to train
for that 100
you can't completely train for that
it's not it doesn't sugarcoat
and then the last one is the
apprehension that you might not measure
up as a marine under fire or let your
buddies down may be common among your
marines all of your marines want to be
successful their fears pl their fears
may play on this desire and they may be
deathly afraid of letting you or their
fellow marines down this particular fear
may serve as a positive factor by
keeping your unit cohesive during battle
it could be detrimental if the fear
overcomes the desire to succeed
and they've got a quote in here from sla
marshall men against fire when fires
when fire sweeps the field nothing keeps
a man from running
except a sense of honor the bound
obligation
to the people right around him of fear
of failure in their sight which might
eternally disgrace him
so it's it's interesting to think about
so this is
like it says a positive factor
so how does it become a negative factor
it becomes a negative factor when your
fear of letting people down
doesn't allow you to actually go and do
something so if you
obviously on the battlefield that could
be a thing hey i'm not gonna i don't
want to i don't want to take charge of
that i don't want to step up because i
don't want to make a bad decision i
don't want to let my friends down
and it can happen in everyday life and
this this does happen in everyday life
right people don't want to look stupid
people don't want to have people
uh say oh you know jocko failed
jocko's a loser so instead i just don't
try anything
so we have to be careful of that
this is i think a good thing to think
about
is
even though people let's say you try
something echo charles and you fail
i might even verbally oh echo see he's a
loser but you know what i think
subconsciously and in some cases
consciously
everybody knows everybody respects that
you've got you know you got up you you
took a swing right took a swing at bat
and and especially if they're cowards
themselves and it's really easy to sit
in the
in the in the in the audience and watch
and poke fun yeah right yeah don't be
that person that sits in the audience
and pokes fun yeah
get up to bat
don't be afraid of looking bad i guess
my point is don't be afraid of looking
bad because you don't actually look bad
when you make an attempt when you step
up people respect it even if they try
and bring you down they're they're lying
they're just trying to bring you down
because they know that you stepped up
and they didn't yeah
don't be afraid of that
and the last source of fear is fatigue
both mental and physical fatigue is a
source of fear as you become exhausted
your ability to reason may begin to
deteriorate as you become more and more
tired you may become indecisive and slow
in carrying out your orders
when confronted daily and constantly
with the stress of combat coupled with
fatigue you and your marines may feel
helpless and unable to continue the
fight
and they've got a quote in here
from major general heart
from a book called determination in
battle it says there's no doubt that
troops however well led can only take
the stress of battle for so long
then they break
ask any commander at any level who tries
to overdraw the account
is courting disaster the mental and the
physical
constantly interact
therefore physical fatigue hunger
disease thirst and above all the stress
of adverse climactic
climatic conditions can reduce the
physical state of the soldier
to such an extent
that his will to fight will be broken
fatigue makes cowards of us all echo
charles yes sir
it does do you agree with that
do you feel like i'm personally
attacking you right now yeah i do 100
yeah that that is
a disturbing thing but this is something
that
you don't fall prey to it quite as much
but man in the early days of jiu jitsu
and by early days i mean when you were
like a purple belt
you didn't like getting tired at all no
it used to really bother you i still
don't like getting tagged
but
i think you know when you can kind of
reconcile the whole big picture where
you know you know this this kind of
it's obvious now we're like okay the
best way to fight your fear is to get
used to that thing that's that you know
that you don't like or whatever so yeah
so yeah you condition but but here's
this is how i know that i still don't
like it
where like if i didn't if i haven't done
any conditioning for a while and i'm
like i gotta get back into conditioning
that first day i'm like oh my god this
is i can feel it it's like
is it is i wouldn't call it a fear of
the conditioning but you ever had a word
yeah like you know okay you know how you
talk about the 20 rep squats right you
know when you got the 20 reps squats
coming and you know that pain is coming
[Music]
you know you kind of get the butterflies
a little bit before they i mean i don't
know if you do
uh
i don't get the butterflies i i get like
the
[Music]
i get rationalization
you know so i'll be thinking ah you know
what i don't
this is is this really kind of the
workout that's really good for you you
know what i mean i like to start having
all these conversations with myself yeah
and they're just lies
yeah and that's part of it too but mine
was for real like i'll be nervous of the
conditioning like i don't because and
maybe this has a lot to do with like the
kind of workouts that i've always liked
done or whatever where you kind of have
a standard where you you know okay so if
i have four exercises then i'm gonna do
as part of a conditioning circuit i have
four exercises and i do one
the other do the other the other end and
have a timed rest in between like you
know 20 seconds or 30 seconds or do them
all with no rest and then rest 30
seconds or whatever
to me if i don't if i have to rest more
than 30 the 30 seconds like i can't
go you know like i can't like you know
30 seconds comes and i can't go because
i got to rest more i failed the workout
it's like going for a pr and failing it
right how long how do you measure the 30
seconds i have a clock going
what do you press start when you get to
the end of whatever you're doing no so
you just have the stopwatch going so you
start it and then you do it and you keep
the stopwatch at that first circuit
so when you're done and you're back to
the first circuit or you're you're
finished the last circuit you see and
you you do the math in your hands oh you
just rub the math yeah
do you ever do workouts where you're not
thinking straight like as far as running
math because sometimes when i'm i'm not
running math yeah it's an added thing
there's just some things going on that's
not happening yeah 30 seconds is easy
though yeah to run the math but oh yeah
it's an additional mental thing that
kind of is like no mental conditioning
but i'll be nervous though before it
like if i don't if i haven't been doing
it for a while i'll be like kind of
nervous like what if i can't do it you
know it's my workout what the hell what
am i scared of you know
but it's like i'll have that thought
it's weird
all right well that's an effective fear
which is the next
section here
effects on the squad
fear is infectious
it can destroy the effectiveness of your
squad recognize fear and deal with it
promptly
boy is that important as a leader
automatic body reactions physically your
body reacts when threatened or when you
anticipate danger listed below are
automatic body reactions to fear
trembling
heart pounding irrational laughter
sweating tunnel vision
auditory exclusion
fight or flight response
have you ever been trembling in fear
before
no not that i can what about so when
you're getting ready for one of these
workouts that you're scared of i'm not
trembling here now
have you ever
i remember sometimes we were getting
ready to do an op like i look at some
people in the room and sometimes they
not tr i'm trembling no
but uh like shaking like uh like tapping
their foot real hard and just that kind
of stuff you know um moving around a lot
yeah super nervous well that makes sense
100 yeah you're going going on a
military operation yes sir i understand
that but no i haven't been on a military
operation so
you know what i guess in football games
before football games i'd yawn all the
time for nowhere yeah that's one of
those things it's like involuntary yeah
where it's weird but what about
uh your stomach
yes you know like i'm feeling a little
bit sick yeah so it'd be and it wouldn't
be my stomach i'd have a weird gag
reflex and remember remember scott
catlin oh yeah yeah so he would like
every once in a while he'd be at the
tournament with me or whatever and he'd
be in training with me and stuff a lot
so
in the tournaments like before my first
match only
i'd i'd have a weird gag like almost
like i want to throw up
and i didn't feel consciously nervous
but
obviously you were obviously yeah my
body was like dude i wouldn't like throw
up but i'd have a weird gag thing and
he'd be like don't start that now
and actually you know what though what i
messed up here is that this is
well i guess it's not it's not it is
fear i was going to say maybe this is
just about fatigue because it says
fatigue causes fear i was thinking that
this was just fatigue but no this is
actually just what fear does to you
some psychological reactions to
inability to make decisions obsession
with minor details oh i've seen that
before
lack of confidence
breakdown of discipline you in in um
psychology
for
the incompetence military incompetence
he talked about how some leaders would
become obsessed with details yeah again
that's just because they were just
scared yeah they're like oh we need to
do this again oh let me go let me get
here yeah yeah something to watch out
for
some extreme reactions to fear occur
when the individual has confronted a
situation where death appears to be
imminent
during such instances two basic forms of
behavior have been observed aggression
and rage one
freezing under fire
two go into some details aggression and
rage
from combat motivation by anthony
kellett was a is a statement from a
german soldier on the eastern front
during world war ii describing how
german soldiers reacted when overrun by
russian hordes the quote below describes
aggression and rage we fought like rats
which do not hesitate to spring with all
their teeth bared when they are cornered
by a man infinitely larger than they are
and then freezing under fire the other
end of the spectrum
from men against fire by sla marshall
came the term freezing under
writing about action in omaha beach
world war ii the quote below describes
freezing under fire they sat there
numbly in the line of fire their minds
blanked out their fingers too nervous to
hold a weapon
fight or flight that's what we're
talking about
and here's some conditions that
stimulate fear
you got to overcome your own fears
though you share the same risks and fear
you must be able to overcome your own
fear and provide the leadership
necessary to achieve success in combat
the marines you lead are your marines
you have lived trained sweated and grown
into an effective fighting unit together
before you face a violent brutal and
cunning enemy you must understand the
conditions that stimulate fear inspire
confidence and encourage in encouraging
your marines
there's a quote here from battle
leadership captain von schell which we
covered on like i don't know maybe the
fourth or fifth podcast here in peace we
learn
how to lead companies battalions
regiments even divisions and armies
we learn in books and by maps how one
fights and wins battles but we are not
instructed in the thoughts the hopes the
fears that run riot in the mind of the
front line soldier
there are three conditions that
stimulate fear
unexpected unknown
and feelings of helplessness
that's a good breakdown yes it is
unexpected well yeah unknown uh oh yeah
and helplessness oh yeah and i think
that's the tired part right where tired
fatigue is it's like part of fear yeah
because you know you're gonna be
helpless straight up
unexpected
enemy actions that appear as a surprise
will have a powerful impact upon your
marines being surprised by the enemy has
been described as causing the quote will
that controls fear
to sag and crumble
end quote when your marines begin to
sense that they do not have control over
their situation they may begin to panic
at such moments you must exert a strong
influence upon them to maintain control
over the unit's actions
surprise is a big deal and you know i i
can't help but but think of this i also
think of the other end of the spectrum
the opposite end of the spectrum which
is
what you want to impose surprise on your
enemy
right you want to that's one of the
speed surprise and violence of action
like one of the mottos of the seal teams
and really of combat in general
because that's what it does it just it's
the same thing you know like on the mats
that surprise thing
that's when you get caught
unknown
your marines will worry about what they
have not seen
and what they do not know
you will have a tendency to think the
enemy is much greater in strength or
ability but really is not do not be
deceived as to enemy strength or
capabilities through exaggerated
impressions this is mikey and the
dragons
right the dragons who think the dragons
are all be big and scary but they're not
and this is something important to think
about because
the context here is like hey you're
leading troops and they're scared of the
enemy they're scared of your competitor
they think the competitors got all the
advantages they don't
feelings of helplessness you
and it's got that capitalized you must
prevent this from taking hold
act to direct and inspire the response
against the enemy everyone has a job
that must be accomplished ensure that
everyone is doing what must be done
and this is key action is a way to
prevent this condition from taking hold
keep your marines busy now look i
i don't like saying key people busy and
they do actually talk about this a
decent amount in this book but i have to
admit that it is true
the the same thing that causes an
individual to get obsessed with some
details
is the same thing when you're t they're
trying to distract their mind from
what's going on so you can actually
utilize
activity to prevent this but also
so there's there's one thing like oh i
can see that echo's nervous about
tomorrow hey echo can you do me a favor
and
you know help me load up the the
vehicles with water and you're like okay
because now you're thinking about that
that's one part of it like almost an
administrative part of it but then also
if there's something happening
for
if we're in a gunfight
and you start freaking out or you're
starting to look scared you know it's
echo get over there pick up security in
that door okay now you got something to
do you got you know so
there's an administrative way to do it
and there's also a
an active
moment to actually give people direction
and as soon as we're taking action
we're moving in the right direction
we're moving in the right direction if
we're taking action one of the worst
things we can do is let the team sit
there and dwell over what's unfolding
around us let's do something
there's an example in here
he was firing behind a log his face was
gray his eyes were dull and without hope
he stopped firing and looked around
it didn't do any good he said
his voice was flat and he was speaking
to no one in particular
i got three of them but did do any good
they just kept coming they just keep
coming
platoon sergeant casimir
palakowski
known as ski
said what the hell are you beefing at
you get paid for it don't you
the kid managed to grin as skee crawled
on down the line
the boy
now a man
was once more squeezing him off
that's from a book called guadalcanal
diary
richard tregaskis
leadership role
additionally the first shock of
realizing that the enemy actually
intends to kill you is a powerful factor
that everyone will face until this
threshold is crossed and your marines
become accustomed to the to functioning
under fire
you must act decisively to ignite the
confidence and individual actions that
will transform fear into an aggressive
response
your presence as a leader has tremendous
value in overcoming fear particularly at
night adverse weather or during lulls in
the action during these times
imaginations run wild
and your marines
think they may be alone or isolated
so again
taking action and and
[Music]
influencing there to be action in these
moments when people are nervous or
scared that's a great move
to overcome fear next section is
stresses of combat
and again these are extreme examples
this is combat examples but there's
stress in every job there's stress in
every business they're stressing life
killing the enemy that's trying to kill
you is only half the battle
to your marines enduring discomfort
fatigue and the other hazards and
stresses of combat is what must be done
so they can succeed in combat sources of
stress in combat fatigue discomfort
casualties boredom
as you become for fatigue as you become
increasingly tired you will lose the
ability to make decisions rapidly you
will become more easily confused
disoriented and ultimately ineffective
you must understand the effects of
fatigue on yourself and your marines and
when to provide for rest especially
amidst the chaos of battle
here's some key indicators of fatigue
reckless disregard for safety yourself
of self or fellow marines excessive
caution or unwillingness to expose
oneself to risk failure to fire weapons
lack of concern for the condition of
weapons or other equipment lack of
concern for personal cleanliness
so all those things are
what we need to watch out for as leaders
when people are not engaged anymore
develop here's some things you can do
develop a sleep plan for your unit that
to ensure that everyone including
yourself
gets a minimum of four hours of sleep
per day situation permitting
[Laughter]
rest is preventative treatment that
keeps senseless casualties from
occurring
so there you go echo charles got to make
sure make sure i want you to make sure
you get four hours yes okay all right
uh hey listen for those people that are
freak out
because i wake up early
and think i hate sleep i don't hate
sleep sleep is good for you you should
sleep a bunch it's when you heal it's
when you get strong it's how you
maintain your
your mental and physical health
so you should sleep and you should sleep
a lot which is why i thought it was kind
of funny that they said hey look hey at
a minimum you got to get four hours
i will say that's a number though in in
[Music]
extreme situations
four hours is a
is like something that you can maintain
function on for a long period of time
i know i can
under four hours and it starts to chip
away at me after a while
but if i can sleep for four hours i'm
kind of stoked a little bit
no and on a normal day you know like
normal day-to-day life i sleep like six
hours you know
because that's what the body needs some
people's eight some people it's five you
know different
uh marines
adversely suffering from the effects of
being cold wet hungry thirsty or weary
will
will determine their ability to fight
well marines tend to develop a high
tolerance for enduring the extremes of
weather without much support however
there is a point where morale is
affected and your unit's actual ability
to fight becomes questionable
at the first opportunity provide dry
clothing protection from the elements
food and water
there you go
sources of stress in combat
the following excerpt from battle at
best
by sla marshall describes how taking
care of your marines pays its dividends
in combat
and again we covered sla marshall
on this podcast i forget what number
and there's some
definite concerns with the veracity of
him
and some of the information that he put
out but as i said when we cover on the
podcast don't throw out the baby with
the bathwater
this is a really interesting case
at dark on 8 december the snow fall
ceased and the cold intensified
down along the canyon road near the
watergate a brisk wind was piling the
drifts as high as a man's head
at the battalion cp which was partly
sheltered by the canyon wall the
thermometer read
30 degrees below zero
up on the wind swept crags where able
company was clearing chinese dead from
the bunkers to make room for its own
ranks
and at the same time preparing to
evacuate its own casualties down the
iced slopes of the mountains
it must have been
a touch colder than that
though there was no reading of the
temperature
all batteries had frozen
weapons were stiffening
the camp
long since had run out of water because
the freezing of canteens
to ease their thirst the men ate snow
and seemed to thrive on it
but of the many problems raised by the
weather the most severe one was getting
an average good man to observe what the
field manual so easily describe as a
quote common sense precaution
for example
prior to marching captain barrow of abel
made certain that each of his men
carried two spare pairs of socks
but that safeguard did not of itself
ensure his force
though the men with feet
sweated from the rigors of the day were
all at the point of becoming frostbite
casualties by the hour of the
bivouac
and here's what here's what captain
barrow said
i learned that night
that only leadership will save men under
winter conditions
it's easy to say that men should change
socks getting it done is another matter
boot laces become iced over during
prolonged engagements and snow drifts
it's a fight to get a boot off the foot
when a man removes his gloves to
struggle with the laces it seems to him
that his hands are freezing his impulse
is all against it
so i found it necessary to do this by
order
staying with the individuals until they
had changed
then making them get up and move about
to restore circulation
that process simple in the telling
consumed hours by the time beryl was
satisfied that his command was
relatively snug it was wearing on toward
midnight right then his perimeter was
hit by a counter attack an enemy force
in platoon strength plus striking along
the ridgeline
from a prop from 1081 in approximately
the same formation which barely used
during the afternoon
all that needs to be told of this small
action is summed up in barrow's brief
radio report they hit us we killed them
all all that we could see
we have counted 18 fresh bodies just
outside our lines
and by the way this is captain barrel
that became the 27th commandant
so he had to go person to person and
physically make sure they were doing
exactly what he told them to do
because the tendency is to curl up into
a ball and die
and you know we we covered uh some of
the or one of the prison camps in korea
and that
that individual specifically talked
about that decision
as there was people that just they just
gave up
and they're not going to do anything
else and they're not going to try and
they just accepted death and the guys
that lived were the guys that said no
i'm not going to give up
but these little things like you know
your feet are sweating and your socks
are wet from working all day climbing up
this mountain and then you get up there
and you're going to be up there for a
while you have to change your socks or
else you're going to freeze
and your ices are laced up and it's
colder than 30 degrees below zero
here's another source of stress in
combat casualties seeing a fellow marine
go down has a traumatic impact upon you
and your marines brutal combat is brutal
and casualties are to be expected the
shock of seeing your buddies wounded or
killed in the possibility that may
happen to them adds to the fear and
apprehension of the survivors
it increases your marines reluctance to
take risks and obey you
how individuals respond after their
units taking casualties is a key
indicator of their effectiveness
of their training self-discipline and
preparation for combat
proper care for your wounded has a great
effect upon morale assuring your marines
that if they are hit their fellow
marines will take care of them there's
an unwritten code among marines that if
wounded and unable to fend for yourself
another marine will come to your aid and
and look that exists in the marine corps
but that should exist in your team too
in your organization someone has a
problem someone has an issue someone has
a sick kid someone has
they get sick themselves and you take
care of them
that's going to help them it's gonna
it's gonna bring your unit closer
together
says your marines need to recognize that
the quicker they take the objective the
quicker their fallen comrades get help
stopping to take care of your fellow
marines during the assault will bog down
the unit during the assault marines
cannot stop the aid of fallen comrade
the corpsman will take care of the
casualties in the best possible manner
until you are able to send for help
that's something we learned basically
day one win the fight
that's also a prioritize and execute
scenario
that's probably the first prioritize and
execute thing that i ever learned
you got to win the fight
at the first opportunity leaders and
comrades should look for casualties
every marine must be accounted for dead
and wounded are removed from the combat
area as soon as possible
and he's got a section here about
boredom in combat the squad leader
should fight inactivity and boredom with
the same tenacity used against enemy
troops
that might be a bit strong
[Music]
look i don't want my troops to be bored
but i'm going to be more tenacious
against the enemy than i am against
boredom
the boredom and that inactivity produces
can negatively impact your squad if they
become complacent when the time comes
when the time for combat comes this
inactivity may result in a less
effective unit
and there's another thing this
one thing that
i think is good good to think about if
you push somebody if you if you're
giving someone something to do kind of
making almost making it up not quite but
like hey we're going to run this battle
drill again hey we're going to do
another briefing hey we're going to
review this hey we're going to maintain
our weapons again
if you're doing that kind of stuff
you should you should give them time for
hey
right now we got an hour relax
you should give them a specific amount
of time to stand down to relax to take a
knee whatever
i think that is important too if you're
trying to keep them busy all the time
that's not smart
you need to find a moment to go okay hey
we got a half an hour everybody take
your take your rock off relax
yeah see here it says keep your marines
occupied by delivery intelligence briefs
reviewing the rules of engagement
rehearsing immediate action drills
during the lulls and pace of operations
by doing so so you prevent disciplinary
problems by turning your squads thoughts
away from them
themselves to the work at hand again
good yes i like it i agree with it
however comma
you've got to give people a little bit
of down time
is that kind of parallel whatever to uh
the idea of you know okay so you go to
the gym we'll say right so let's say you
want to go to the gym after work
not before work right after work
so if you let's say as a routine you go
from work you get off work and then you
go
straight to the gym that's better
than going home first
decompressing a little bit then going to
the gym right you know
i don't know if what you're talking
about is the same thing but it's 100
true i think so though because they're
you know when you get like downtime or
whatever like too much downtime
essentially right like where it's not
like you have to rest and recover from
work to go to the gym unless you do and
that's a whole different thing yeah i'm
talking about the idea that you come
home from your office you know and
you're physically not exhausted maybe
mentally or but whatever you go straight
to the gym because you don't give your
your mind
just like i said a chance to think about
like yourself your own like how am i
feeling i mean the mood and it's like it
kind of creeps up on you you know when
you have that downtime but if you go
straight to the gym you're like hey
we're still we're still moving you know
yeah you don't get a chance to that's
true that is that is accurate
and then
if you take that to the extreme where
you also knew not get any rest at all
you don't have any downtime then you
gotta watch out for that yeah that's
almost like the idea that let's say your
your job is like super physically
demanding like you're what would you
would you say a drywall hanger or
something drywall just getting after it
yeah well that's one that you said you
did and it was kind of hard either way
let's say you did you know 11 12 hours
let's say roofer roofer yeah in the hot
sun even
boom okay go home take a little snoozer
even
then hit the gym you can be kind of like
refreshed a little bit i bet you'd be
better off just going straight there
though
i think so something i think there's
plenty of people here at our gym where
they're coming off of a long day of work
and construction and then it's like
right onto the mats you know
i think that's a better move bro i would
for me it's a better move mentally it's
a better move i think yeah physically no
you go
recover a little bit that's what i think
you're driving here you know you got
like a half an hour or whatever that's
what i'm saying mentally but because
when you're driving here you're thinking
about training more than you're thinking
about relaxing i'll tell you that you go
home
have a snack turn on the tv just for a
little bit you're letting the window
close that was one of the better
conversations we once had was you're
letting that window close yeah it's like
oh it's getting a little bit smaller a
little bit smaller oh can't make it oh
you know i got a little too busy
sometimes my wife will wake up early
hell yeah
and
like
there's that you know whatever that uh
gravity
of you know she's oh you know talking to
me and stuff all right yes yeah yeah oh
yeah
but we have workouts to do
you know
but
come back down to the house to like grab
some more water or something
because i'm in my garage you know
uh and then i go back down to like grab
some water
and she's awake
and she's having a cup of tea because
she's from england oh yeah and she said
oh morning and i'm like and there's that
gravity you know
you kind of wish she honestly no offense
to my wife i kind of wish she wasn't
awake because i kind of want to like
hang out with her a bit you know yes i
have to not oh yeah that's real that's
real even with us
when we show up here whatever we want to
talk about some stuff you know do this
do that yeah the workout thing
especially with your wife because even
if you don't want to talk to your wife
i'm not saying that's my case
maybe
either way even if you don't want to
talk hypothetically hypothetically you
can't just disrespect her and be like
yeah cool story i'm busy she knows what
you're doing you're working out take a
minute talk to me i'm your wife you know
for better or worse all this stuff and
you're over here just dissing me for
like some
curls or whatever you're doing in there
you see what i'm saying and that's what
it really does feel like when you're
doing it
so yeah i can jam you
on i hope my wife sleeps i like when
she's i like it when she sleeps a little
later you know get gets her rest yeah
get some rest go dig it get some rest
um
success in combat the focus of this
study unit is to teach you the important
factors of leadership so you can perform
better as a leader in both peacetime and
in combat
the way that you respond to these
leadership challenges is crucial to
achieving success and combat factors to
success
as an infantry squad leader
you control the lives of 12 marines
they look to you for instruction and
guidance
this part is important
your most casual remark will be
remembered
your clothing vocabulary and method of
leadership will be imitated
they're listening
and and it has impact
when you start making little cracking
jokes about the
lt
the those jokes have a lot more impact
when they're coming from you as a squad
leader what's the lt the lieutenant oh
gotcha
when you're cracking jokes about the vp
of sales
yeah your little sales team is
that those those have more impact than
you think i this is something i always
had to like be careful to when i went
from being
maybe it's even to this day when i went
from from being an e5 and a platoon e5
mafia where everybody is a target
everybody in the entire chain of command
is a target for ridicule yeah
and then all of a sudden when i became
you know like an officer assistant
platoon commander platoon commander i
had to freaking dial that back you know
you just can't be going dropping napalm
on that chain of command over every
little thing
and it's tempting because it's funny and
that's what you're used to
i had to dial that back lathe always
cracks up when i like go e5 on somebody
you know i start dropping the hammer on
someone
yeah
hey this is a side note okay so you
always talk about that like the e5 yeah
it's like a
think yeah e5 mafia e5 mafia and i've
heard of e4
i think um yeah e and then e6 of course
what's with e5 that sounds to me that
sounds pretty high like
there's e1 right is there an e1 z1 but
you're not a new one for very long
you're liking boot camp your knee one
you're probably gonna make e2 out of
boot camp e3 you should be pretty much
you know within maybe i don't know a
year yeah then your e4
so now you could be e4 for like a few a
couple years you know maybe two three
years
so you
you may you may or may not have done a
deployment this is also back in the day
guys make rank faster now than we did
so back in the day
the
e6 was a leadership position okay
e5 was the boys
and the new guys were kind of e4s maybe
even e3s occasionally so
essentially i don't think there's an e3
in a sealed platoon today at all
i don't think there is i think they're i
think there's barely any e4s it's mostly
e5s and now you'll have multiple e6's in
a platoon but back in the day an e6
was an lpo he was the leading penny
officer then you had a chief petty
officer then you had the assistant
platoon come in and platoon commander
so you had those were the senior people
we called them the top four okay
and then you had new guys you had four
or five new guys which were probably e3s
no they were probably e4s maybe an e3
and then you had the group in the middle
right and these were the e5 mob so they
were they're not
when you say their
e6 leadership position so e5 is not only
like they're not anyone's boss they're
they're just the right guys now they
they they might be one they might be a
new guy's boss like when i was an e5
mobster i had an e4 that was a new guy
that was a radio man yeah you see what
i'm saying yeah
i'm trying to trying to draw comparison
and actually part of the time i was in
the e5 mafia i was an e4
because i didn't make e5 very rapidly
so
yeah but that e5 mafia is like the
people that are doing the work right
right like when you were a bouncer how
many bouncers were there uh i don't know
15. okay this is it now one of them was
in charge right yeah maybe two of them
hey this guy's in charge or whatever
yeah so those guys are in charge of then
you had
a couple
like
new guys that kind of sucked or whatever
yeah but then you had a core group of
guys that kind of if you could say
something people are gonna have to
listen yeah there you go that's your e5
mafia yeah you know what it was and now
that i'm thinking of it it's
there's the door guys they're all called
door guys but the guys who work the
front door which is usually the one and
two and then like a kind of a
guy who would switch out someone who's
doing well but and then there's the rest
of the guys who worked you know inside
and then yes there were like new guys
who were like still learning like okay
bro
yeah yes and kind of the same thing
where you could tell them hey go
change the toilet paper in the bathroom
yeah you know like go do the worst guy
yeah exactly right so yeah i get i got
you yeah so p5 is kind of high though is
what i'm saying it's like well i can no
it's not kinda high
but in a sealed platoon you're
a mid level
but you're kind of just a shooter too
you know
you don't you're not one of the top four
yeah
so it's not like kinda high and right
now everybody i think i think everybody
in the seal teams right now is an e5 if
you make it through buzz i think you
become an e5 it's kind of legit you know
back in the day he was like no sorry bro
you're an e3 you're an e4
back in the day if you're on a ship and
you're an e3 you had to work in the
dishwashing for three months
and we did one deployment we had an e3
in our platoon and we somehow got him
out of it
got him out of doing that
but i was an e4
for my
second platoon so even though i should
have been an e5 or i was in the e5 mafia
when i was an e4 but even then even in
that platoon
there's a bunch of e4s and we're all in
e5 mafia what does the e stand for
enlisted
and then if you're an officer it's an oh
so you got o1 that's an ensign
o2 is lieutenant junior grade see that's
weird i've never heard of oh anything
all i heard was e
i think i've even heard of e1 e2 e3 yeah
because people talk smack about the like
oh that guy's an e1
and then you become
an in the navy o3 is
lieutenant and then o4
is lieutenant commander but in the army
that same rank is called a major
so
when when in ramadi
the army guys
they a lot of army guys would call me
major right
so then some of the
some of my guys would call me the mage
that makes sense yeah so there you go
and then captain isn't very high or it
is a captain in the army and the marine
corps is an 0
captain or sorry is it 03 in the army
and the marine corps which is
a company commander in charge of 150
guys
uh
a captain in the navy
is much higher it's an o6
and they could be in charge of multiple
ships
so
a captain in the navy is much higher
rank than a captain in the army or the
marine corps okay
a captain in the navy is a colonel a
full bird you ever heard that expression
probably in the movies you hear that
full bird colonel from you guys so a
full bird colonel
which means they have an eagle on their
collar is a full captain
you don't really say full bird captain
because you don't need to because the
reason you say that is in the army and
the marine corps you could be a
lieutenant colonel which still has a
silver oak leaf
which makes you a lieutenant colonel so
if someone's got the full bird that's
why you because you can still call
someone that's a lieutenant girl you
might just call them colonel because
you're not it's a big mouthful to say
colonel
or sorry it's a big mouthful to say
lieutenant colonel hey lieutenant
colonel what are we doing but if you say
hey colonel that's totally acceptable so
you want to let your boys know like hey
this guy's a full bird colonel
big deal got that full bird curl coming
in yeah i yeah i understand why
i'm i understand now why i was so
unclear about everything because it's
like same words
different you know army's different than
navy and but same words you know yeah
well sometimes leif and seth would get
called
captain
by army guys spimer because that's you
see those two bars like oh that's a
captain if you're in the army that's a
captain yeah so you're not thinking
lieutenant because the lieutenant is a
lower rank
check
all right
this section breaks out two things there
are two fundamental types of factors
that affect success in combat
one factors over which you have little
or no influence that you must try to
understand endure and explain to your
marines
and number two factors that you can
influence directly through your
leadership
and it goes into a bunch of things well
that you can't that you have little to
no influence political guidelines and
rules of engagement available
availability and quality of replacements
location weather terrain public reaction
and support type of conflict enemy
action duration you know control very
little control over those things
and it goes into talking about the
political guidelines
the way you're responsible making sure
your marines abide by them
here's an important part they say pass
through the chain of command information
that might be useful in correcting
deficiencies with rules of engagement
procedures so if you've got some rule of
engagement that doesn't make sense you
are responsible for sending that a chain
of command
and by the way if you work in a
factory and there's some part of
the manufacturing line that doesn't make
sense you are responsible for running
that up the chain so it can get
corrected
little control over
who's going to replace you obviously
no control very little control over
location terrain weather
so it list goes into a little bit of
detail on those things then it goes into
factors that you can influence
morale motivation discipline esprit de
corps proficiency
morale is the mental and emotional
condition
enthusiasm
confidence or loyalty of an individual
or group with regard to the functions or
tasks at hand the squad leader who taps
into this valuable resource and keeps it
to the forefront throughout the adverse
conditions of combat will always prevail
that's a strong word always
motivation is a byproduct of morale
if your marines are enthusiastic about
being part of the squad and have
confidence in their squad leader then
they will have the incense incentive to
drive on through adversity
discipline
discipline is defined in the dictionary
as quote to bring under control
in combat we speak of discipline in
troops we speak of the marines ability
to disregard the natural tendencies of
self-preservation and at times put them
in harm's way if necessary and i would
expand on this right now but they expand
on this in a beautiful way they'll talk
about discipline in a beautiful way
coming up esprit de corps is the unit
spirit
describes how devoted and loyal they are
to the team proficiency
proficiency is being knowledgeable and
skillful in your craft craft imagine a
unit being so confident in their ability
to perform that it affects all of the
aforementioned factors now you have our
unit ready to fight morale motivation is
the cornerstone of discipline
esprit de corps
and proficiency if you instill high
morale and motivation in your marines
this can lead to success in combat
morale makes up three quarters of the
game the relative balance of manpower
makes up only the remaining quarter
that's napoleon bonaparte
morale makes up three quarters of the
game
in combat
you know
that's one of those ones you go well
yeah cuz you know if you're thinking you
know your football team against another
football team and they have great morale
but you guys are better players yeah
right well it's probably not going to
work out too well but because this is
what i was thinking about last night i
was like well you know where is that
going to really carry you in a football
game
but then i thought what if you what if
your football game was played for months
you see what i'm saying yeah and it
wasn't about how big and strong you were
but it was about hey we're going to be
we're going to maneuver faster than you
we're going to
walk further than you we're going to
keep working while you're resting
like though we're going to keep our
weapons clean like all those things like
that's how you win yeah and all those
things have to do with morale
so it might not make a sense in a short
engagement in a physical game
it can have an impact
for sure i would almost say
you were right to begin with
in a football game as far as the example
i mean you're right either way but
if your morale is low the other team is
high
but you have a better football team your
morale is going to be low for a reason
like base essentially like oh you know
it's like there's going to be in low
morale it's going to be a lack of
confidence i'm sure there's going to be
a lack of motivation and according to
the book lack of proficiency which
negatively affects your morale so when
you know you're not that good your
morale is down exactly right so like i
said it's for a reason so their morale
is good what if like everyone your
morale if you're a better quote unquote
better football team is gonna be for a
reason and then whatever that reason is
i don't know it's your hypothetical so i
don't know but think of a realistic one
maybe
people are arguing about this and that
so they're not working together as a
team oh the morale on the team itself
like what can hurt the morale exactly
right like on the better quarantine
quote-unquote team yeah like you like
you blew a game like you blew the last
game like you shouldn't have missed the
field goal and you did and you were a
better team than them but then they won
morale could be down yeah and you're
arguing with your team quarterbacks is
blaming everyone they you know maybe
their best guy is injured and that you
know now everyone's not as confident and
like maybe they're starting you know all
this other stuff and they're tired
because they've been drinking you know
all this stuff so technically there's a
i'm just saying that's that's a big
factor a lot of times so
so technically they they are maybe a
better team but the mural is so low for
these specific reasons the other guys
have been working hard they even got a
strategy in place a secret strategy i
told you about this one time this team
was we were technically better than them
but they were like saying oh we're going
to kick their ass we're going to kick
their ass and they're telling the whole
island essentially we're going to kick
their ass so this was this high school
yeah
and i was like what the this is uncanny
the re the way they're saying this so
much you know and then but they had a
little plan and they did they beat us
too with a plan what was the plan it was
uh to do these weird quarterback keep
plays with no huddle
so it's just essentially that ascent uh
that surprise kind of thing and then
just keep going going going so they'd go
quarterback keep and we'd kind of stop
it then they go no how do quarterback
keep and be like oh we're scrambling and
we kind of stop it but they gain a
little bit more and they just kept doing
it kept doing it for the whole but
didn't you figure out a solution for it
after they did it four or seven or nine
times
i think or was it two i think our morale
went down in that first flurry to be
honest with you um i forget how it's so
their morale was high very high i
actually beat you yeah for that reason
i'm always surprised in football that
there's not more sneakiness
yeah
i think a lot of sneakiness and
i feel like we might have talked about
this with football there's so much
history behind the way plays work
that
sneakiness usually comes with an element
of risk that's equal
so
yeah if you do trick play like there's a
there's teams that could sort of lend
towards more sneakiness but they lend
more towards risk as well so like one of
the mainstream sneaky plays is called a
reverse where
it's like you give the ball there's many
ways to do it but a standard one would
be you give the ball to the running back
in an outside run and instead of keeping
running the wide receiver who's way over
there he comes around this way so he's
acting like he's right and he gives it
to the wide receiver going the other way
so the defense has all this momentum
going this way with the ball and the
reverse just comes around with but he's
a single guy because he has no blockers
if he had blockers everyone would see
the blockers going over there and they'd
be like oh wait this isn't you know this
so they'd be wearing the risk being that
if somebody picks it up and reads the
play then he's getting
annihilated probably behind the line
because he has no blockers exactly right
or the what's the one
there's like a hook and lateral which is
a big risk on that one and then uh a
pass back to the quarterback that's
another one where like you give it to
the running back and he runs and he
doesn't go past the line the
quarterbacks does that the quarterback
runs around the other side on a on a
pass pattern essentially a receiver so
he goes down and then now the running
back has to throw the ball to the
quarterback which is huge risk by the
way bro they're going to pick that thing
and the quarterback's got to catch it
gotta catch it he has to be open by the
way because if he's not open who's going
to throw two another wide receiver
usually it's like you know it's you put
your eggs all in one basket a lot of
time
and then
nowadays people are kind of
hip to trick plays so they kind of wait
for it to develop and now the risk goes
up you know so that's probably why i'm
sure back in the in fact
back in the day like 1940s football
that's all kinds of weird places
yeah
so morale
you guys lost the other
platoon team was hyped on their morale
year morale was immediately crushed and
then you were all embarrassed then you
just lost
so even even in football it can be
morale can be
um
three quarters of the game
yeah i think so
it says morale is the confident resolute
willing and often
self-sacrificing and courageous attitude
of a marine to accomplish the tasks
expected by the squad morale is based
upon
pride in the achievement and aims of the
squad faith in you as a squad leader a
sense of participation in the squad's
work devotion and loyalty to the other
members of the squad confidence in the
ultimate success of the squad
whichever army goes into battle stronger
in seoul
their enemies generally cannot withstand
them that's the greek warrior xenophon
more than 2 000 years ago
morale tends to fluctuate even among the
best marines
it must be your constant concern
because this is the foundation of
discipline you must recognize the
extreme importance morale has to the
combat effectiveness of your
squad marine tents or morale tends to
fluctuate even amongst the best marines
that's something that's important to
note
i'll tell you it effect it it fluctuates
less
it can't fluctuate but man you get some
some motivated
troopers
it's hard to even it's hard to even
bring them down a little bit they're
just in the game
and they help everybody
it's so helpful to have somebody kind of
motivated in the game like somebody with
high morale yeah like we got the ass
and it it kind of takes someone who can
deal with adversity right yeah
so and i was thinking which by the way
is a decision
yeah you know and it's a long decision
yeah you can be like look i know what's
happening right now i can see what's
happening i can see the negativity start
to drag down yeah and you can say hey
i'm not letting this happen
on me
yeah and you get crazy so but that guy
who's getting crazy and
um he has to be kind of used to
adversity in one way or another or at
the very least know how to deal with it
that's what yes so
so it kind of brought me back a little
bit to the to a conversation we had
recently about guys quitting who you
whatever it may be um where you would
think no way this guy's going to quit
because he's he's a stud
but
this guy is probably not you you get an
you know in mma well yes or whatever
in
dick marcinko's book who recently died
the rogue warrior
he wrote a book came out in 1992 when i
was a new guy in the herbs
but he called these people gazelles
right yes yeah and he said gazelles
they they're used to winning yeah
they're right they run they win and they
run they win and they're just good
athletes and they're just winning
winning winning and they show up at buds
and you i can promise you
there's gonna be some you lose
and if that's
you hit that adversity wall and you've
been a stud
your whole life and all of a sudden it
i'm sure there's multiple psychological
things that can unfold one of them might
be well i'm you're used to winning and
now you lose and you get down yourself
but also hey
this is the hardest thing i've ever done
it's harder than i thought it was going
to be or i failed this thing and now
what's going to happen if i failed this
thing and i'm only two days into this
gig
i got six more months of this yeah and i
i already failed no i'm not i'm not cut
out for this i'm not totally not used to
it it's totally like an imposition on
their whole sensibility and that's just
how just not used to it but so you could
in a way kind of track it back to morale
really
that individual's morale gets crushed
exactly right like cr so you get a guy
who's used to adversity he's like hey
this won't crush my
morale i've been here before i know i
can fight back out of this i know this
is gonna end i know you know guys who
know about adversity but the guy who
doesn't the guy who
wins every single time never failed ever
in his you know and just things come
natural to him yeah oh bro you like that
guy get crushed one time morale is down
yeah
damn that might be the situation on that
one could be so morale is kind of
because in the beginning you'd think
morale that's just you having a bad
attitude about stuff your morale is low
like if you say oh hey my morale is bad
you know i don't have
you kind of
on the surface
it kind of comes off as that like bro
just i don't know fire yourself up like
essentially like make a decision to have
a better attitude what do you think
about this the
the buds when i was going through buds
they would say false motivation is
better than no motivation yeah
i kind of agreed with it yeah you know
yeah
you know like you hear someone start
getting fired up whether they're faking
it or not it's like hey that guy seems
to be stoked let's go rock and roll yeah
exactly right and that's that and you
know how um like
you guys will say like hey if you have
like the the no bad team's only bad
leaders right the boat cruise right
where you get a guy who's kinda like hey
it's all good guys we're gonna do this
and and he's kind of
motivating everybody even if they were
kind of like beat down yeah their morale
kind of gets gets more high on the
academy online the other day i was
talking about how you frame things up
and this is a skill
that you can
attain over time
but
if you gave if you were my boss and you
gave me the worst assignment
ever
by the time i'm telling the team i frame
that thing up in a totally different way
it is not the worst job it's a challenge
it's an opportunity to look awesome
we're going to do better than
everybody's like i'm going to frame
things up all day long
in an uplifting morale moment yeah i'm
definitely not framing something up as
bad
like we're gonna frame this up
and the thing is it's not a lie it's the
truth i can't you can't lie to your team
you can't lie to him and be like well
hey everyone this is going to be great
right we just hey everyone we we got to
work this weekend aren't you excited you
know if you've just been out in the
field for two weeks and then you get
back and the boss says hey you guys got
to do a dog and pony this weekend what
do you mean
oh we got a congressman coming in and we
got to show him our new capabilities and
your platoon's doing it
right you can't be like hey everyone
this is jump for joy no but you can but
you can frame it in a true way
that's listen up
hey
the boss just talked to me
they want the best platoon out here to
represent and do this dog and pony we're
gonna do we're gonna knock this guy's
socks off yeah he's gonna think that
every seal is a damn terminator robot
when he gets done walking through this
stuff we're gonna get more money for the
entire community by kicking ass
you know what i'm saying it's a
different game i'm fired up right now
i'm ready to do a dog and pony show for
a congressman yeah
yeah so i gotta frame stuff correctly
like your kids if they don't like math
you can't be like no math is fun right
you just like that's a lot in their
friends they're like okay i can't really
relate to you at all i can't mention my
trust level is going down
yeah right like even a five-year-old
knows that this is not fun yeah right
exactly
there's a rare person that thinks it's
fun but it's like one in a billion
freaking lex friedman just got fired up
looking at a problem when he's six years
old he's like oh hell yeah yeah yeah
right yep
me not happening lex good to go you
needed a better frame up on that one
yeah like lex framed it up in his mind
that's his good friend yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but yeah no but when you say hey when
you get good at this right here is going
to make you smarter yeah this is you're
going to be able to dominate you're not
going to have to worry about school when
you're dominant in math
you got to learn this problem and people
are like oh i can dominate you
all right characteristics of morale
major general william slim
quoted by john masters in the road pass
the road pass
mandalaya
provides an example of how morale can be
affected in combat
again some of these these things are
really good
quote
we have already trained our men to the
highest possible level of skill with
their weapons and in the use of minor
tactics
but in the end
every important battle develops to a
point where there is no real control by
senior commanders
every soldier feels himself to be alone
discipline may have got him to the place
where he is and discipline may hold him
there
for a time
cooperation with other men in the same
situation can help move him forward
self-preservation will make him defend
himself to the death if there is no
other way
but what makes him go on alone
determined to break the will of the
enemy opposite him
is morale
pride in himself as an independent
thinking man who knows why he's there
and what he's doing
absolute confidence that the best has
been done for him and that his fate is
now in his own hands
the dominant feeling on the battlefield
is loneliness gentlemen and morale only
morale individual morale as a foundation
under training and discipline
will bring victory
and that's see that's what's important
what what i read this a couple times
what's important here is to remember
that as the leader you're the one that's
developing their morale
you're bringing together that unit
you're training them to the utmost
you're you're impo you're
imparting this the benefits of
self-discipline you're rewarding those
things
and you build this creature this this
beast
that has this morale that's so strong
that they're not going down
here's some specific indicators of
morale
response to shortages care of equipment
and weapons rumors excessive quarreling
you brought that one up earlier with the
football team
personal hygiene standards of military
courtesy personal appearance
personal conduct
so like the the responsibilities is how
do they respond with hey we're almost
out of water oh my god we're all gonna
die uh you know the movie aliens yes sir
we're all gonna die out here man right
because there's a shortage of whatever
we don't know if any backups coming
we're all gonna die
that's bad morale
so bad morale is essentially the
beginning of the end yeah so it's kind
of like
the end of the rope kind of a thing of
course you can turn it around but bro
it's the beginning of the end unknown
it's kind of a critical factor
when there's when there it says this and
when they're running when you're running
low on
whatever on on equipment or food or
water it says the squad with heim and
strong unit cohesion will divide what is
available and become an even stronger
outfit because of it the unit that does
not have this quality is not acting
cohesively as a team and will
disintegrate quickly
failure to properly maintain equipment
and weapons indicate that a marine does
not care is becoming excessively
fatigued or has lost all discipline
on the other hand if you fail to provide
the means to keep your marines gear
properly
maintained you can erode their morale
you got rumors clearly there's a lack of
information
you you need to tell your team what's
going on otherwise they're going to make
it up and it's not going to be good
cooperation mutual trust and confidence
in one another's ability can be
adversely affected when your marines
quarrel amongst themselves excessive
calling is a sign that something is
wrong and must be fixed i was going to
say this is like a chicken or an egg
thing
like
when things start going bad people start
to argue and when people start to argue
things start going bad i guess not it's
a downward spiral i don't know which one
starts first chicken or the egg but when
you start hearing people arguing amongst
themselves you're gonna have problems
and it's not gonna get better yeah
uh
keeping it you know keeping it clean
as far as hygiene goes
it says regardless of how miserable the
circumstances may actually be we must do
what we can to make conditions habitable
it talks about this
standards of military courtesy units
that have pride and confidence in their
leaders maintain high standards of
military courtesy at all times
changes show that poor discipline and
lack of respect may indicate low morale
keeping it professional
it's interesting that they talk about
standards of military courtesy but if
you want to translate that to the
civilian world you want to translate it
to your family it's how you treat each
other
because sure in the marine corps salute
means you know i respect you or calling
you sir or whatever staying attention
all those things but when you're a
civilian
if you want to
keep your team's morale high even when
things are going sideways you don't yell
at your team you treat them with respect
you ask them what their ideas are you
know like that's what you do so treating
people with respect is a way to maintain
high morale
it says this about personal conduct
moodiness sulliness quiet withdrawal
or any sudden unexplainable change in
one of your marines behavior
they may indicate that something is
wrong and there's cause for concern
that's the way you're acting
now listen does that mean you want to be
pollyanna
and have a big smile on your face hey
guys we're about to be overrun yay like
no that's not what we're talking about
hey i'm gonna have to fire a bunch of
people from our company
no
but
going into that listen to the it's it's
it's interesting
that they say this sullenness and quiet
withdrawal and moodiness so none of
those say be happy they don't say that
none of them say jump for joy
but if you're acting sullen
if you're if you if you withdraw
if you have an unexplained change in
your behavior man being consistent is so
important from a leadership perspective
that's why i was getting interviewed a
little while ago and they were attacked
asking me about resiliency
and i kind of said that
um this was this was
travis mannion's sister ryan
and she was she was she's got a podcast
about resiliency and i was on it
and she was
asking me about resiliency and i was
like hey i don't think too much about it
and i think it's kind of a little bit
natural for me to be resilient and i
shouldn't have said natural maybe i
didn't say it but but that's the feeling
i get but what i ultimately said was
listen
i feel like i'm fairly resilient because
i don't have low lows and the reason i
don't have low lows because i don't have
high highs
i'm not getting all excited well yay
no i'm not doing that but i'm also like
oh no i'm not doing either one of those
two things
i'm staying in a
in a limited emotional box where i'm not
getting too crazy with a victory and i'm
not getting too crazy with a defeat
so i think that's
that lines up very well with this
if you're if you if you're the person
that shows how happy you are
everybody's used to that and now when
you start being sad they're gonna go
geez echo is all bummed out something's
wrong yeah or even not as happy
like if you know these guys are super
fired up and then you know
something cool happens and then they're
like yeah right on and they're not as
fired up you're like oh something's
wrong even though they essentially
express happiness just not enough
happiness
you ever um kind of back to the the um
professionalism and you know they're
talking about in the military like okay
so
uh what what does your wife call you
normally darling darling not you by your
name huh not generally yeah i've met
barely ever actually yeah mine either
and i don't really call her by her name
that much it's song other stuff we don't
have to go into it but i don't want to
hear them
sometimes they fall if i call her by her
name she'll be like don't call me by my
name like kind of half joking you know
because it kind of sounds but also what
if what if she what if you were
downstairs and she was like echo right
you know exactly right or if if we're
going through some things or in some
sort of almost like argument or whatever
like yeah she won't she'll
thankfully it's been multiple multiple
multiple years it sends anything like
that but even then let's say you're on
bad terms with your wife and usually she
calls you i don't know darling babe
whatever they call we call each other
and then they call you your name you
kinda it's like a little assault on
yourself like kind of like oh there's
something wrong
so when morale is down yeah boom you can
that part breaks down a little bit it's
a little bit disrespectful yeah to call
you
yeah so that's that's it
that's why consistency yeah and keeping
yourself in check and making sure that
you're not
allowing these emotions to creep out
yeah and
cause people to look at you and think oh
echo's really concerned right now this
things are going bad yeah echoes all
stolen right now things
that's good what's going to spread yeah
that's going to affect the morale of
everybody
what's with that with calling someone
who you know good
by their legitimate name
what that is you know how like okay so
in the family you know the old thing
where if they call you like the parent
calls the kid by their first and last
name oh yeah yeah you know that means
they're in trouble like that kind of
stuff yeah
what is that
uh i think it's because of what we're
saying right now
yeah i think it's like a step up in in
in
lack of affection yeah it's like almost
the opposite you know in a small tiny
way where it's like the better terms
we're on the more loose i'm going to be
with what i call you i'll call you more
like fun stuff you know i'll call you by
a nickname or a fun name or a pet name
whatever you call it
and then when things are bad okay now
you're kind of reduced to your
legitimate name your official name okay
let me ask you this
tangential
but if you ever hear people when they
use your name a lot when they're talking
to you yeah it's weird right it is weird
it's like we're trying to establish a
weird salesy type like thing where i
know you
like you know
you know echo
like i don't think i've other than
saying good evening echo i don't think
i've ever said your name on this podcast
because it's a little bit weird right
yeah i mean and even when you do you say
my first and my last name with in which
indicates like a small like it's like
humor like a joke
yeah exactly right but even you'll be
like you echo charles like it's a joke
oh you know where i do say some names on
this specific podcast is if someone else
is here and we're having a three-way
conversation i might say like well if i
was to say to you hey mike or i might
say well that's right you know fred yeah
cause i wanna everyone that's listening
to know that i was saying that to fred
yeah but that's different than what
you're talking it is different it is
i've always
it seems a little bit strange it seems
like something you would learn at like a
at like a a mastermind sales course
to like touch them on the shoulder and
tell say their name a bunch so they feel
closer to you it doesn't do that for me
if you're trying to sell me something
don't say my name because it's probably
gonna like send me the other direction
yeah it's not natural like it doesn't
feel natural at all but some people
that's just how that's just how they
talk yeah but i think that's because
they've been
ingrained to do that i don't think it's
normal yeah
almost like it's like overly
professional almost yeah that's the
thing echo is when you're doing
something
it's weird echo
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right
so i'm glad i confirmed that
it is weird if you listen to podcasts
you can hear people do that sometimes
if you listen to podcasts you'll hear
someone saying
you know and it's sort of like right
that's kind of strange yeah especially
when it's when they're the only yeah
yeah we're the only ones here echo
if you're scolding someone then it then
it rolls out that's true i bet you some
of those scolding videos that we have of
you and me i probably use your name more
often than not i think i'll use your
name oh right because you're not
scolding you're just trying to make fun
okay i think i don't know if i remember
appearances
if a marine begins to look sloppy a
behavioral problem may be the cause
likewise if conditions prevent your
marines from washing shaving or
obtaining clean uniforms for long
periods morale can drop
this is
one of those things where again in the
business world
some hey here's our dress code
hey we got a presentation you're going
to get look sharp smart move
smart move hey and i can tell you i'm
not one of these people that
is
uh going out and getting whatever
whatever a tailor
to make my suit or whatever yeah in fact
i don't really like wearing suits at all
sometimes fighters wear suits have you
noticed that oh yeah that's a little bit
why is that the boxer no no no i'm not
talking about a ufc yeah i know but it
kind of oh it felt it feels like it came
from the old school the boxers right i
feel like i might be disconnected like
and wrong or whatever yeah
you know like i i look at a bo i look at
a fighter and they're putting a suit and
tie on to go to a press conference yeah
i feel like in a million years i i
wouldn't have done that but i do think
there's kind of two camps on that and
then there's a rare few that are kind of
in between where
some guys they that's their jam they
wear suits because they're because
they're a conical sophisticated
professional and that or that's the
image and then there's guys like nick
diaz who's you know just as good if not
better than everyone who will probably
never wear a suit so
it's i think there's two camps yeah it's
definitely two i've fallen to nate diaz
camp on that one i'm just going in that
t-shirt to the press conference probably
showing up late yeah
yeah you cut the show
but you're like that in real life too
though where
you know you you're probably gonna wear
slippers or flip-flops as we call them
here
and shorts and a shirt unless you have
to wear something else yeah that's true
so watch out for that with your people
that's so that's a kind of a classic
thing too though right like even in the
movies where it's like if they want to
indicate visually that this guy has just
let himself go his morale is down he's
down and out what his beard is
unshaven yeah his clothes may or may not
be dirty like that kind
characteristics of motivation motivation
answers the question why do marines
fight motivation is based on a
psychological factors such as needs
desires and impulses that cause a person
to act for a marine
commitment and pride in the unit
and the core is generally the basis for
combat motivation
i was when i was starting to read this
chapter i was like thinking about the
fact that i always say motivation no
factor because motivation is a feeling
it's fickle it comes and goes
and then i just was thinking okay well
how what are the how are they going to
talk about this
and there you go
and i've talked about this on the
podcast motivation is why you're doing
something
and it's important to understand the why
a motivated marine will do what needs to
be done and will know the right thing to
do
with effective leadership and attentive
concern for maintaining high morale
motivation will also be high however
motivation is much more than just an
indicator of morale it is a key element
that must be understood by everyone in
your squad in combat motivation has
special significant two marines
sc smith's u.s marine corps in world war
ii provides an illustration of this
motivation
quote in a foxhole
in the center of the tenuous line he had
done much to hold pfc john ahrens an
able company automatic rifleman lay
quietly his eyes closed breathing slowly
aarons was covered with blood
he was dying
next to him laid a dead jason japanese
sergeant
and flung across his legs a dead
japanese officer
aarons had been hit in the chest twice
by bullets and blood weld slowly from
three deep puncture wounds inflected by
bayonets
around his foxhole
sprawled 13 crumpled japanese bodies
as captain louis w walt gathered aarons
into his arms to carry him to the
residency the dying man
still clinging to his bar
said captain
they tried to come over me last night
but i don't think they made it
they didn't johnny
walt softly replied
they didn't
end quote
and then it goes on to say what will
motivate your marines to fly fight like
pfc irens
what causes them to have this measure of
tenacity and the ability to continue to
fight when others would give up
numerous historian sociologists and
psychologists have studied behavior
under fire in an effort to under to find
out why we fight as we do in explaining
what motivates marine to persevere in
battle many experts have concluded that
the following facts are significant unit
cohesion tradition commitment aggression
patriotism rewards and punishment social
identity
in the unit cohesion section
it says cohesion is perhaps the most
powerful motivational factor in combat
common experiences and shared hardship
stimulate and foster closeness among
individuals as a unit
the result in a unit
that is
able to maintain tactical cohesion and
achieve success in combat if your
marines know their mission it is their
faith in you and their fellow marines
that will carry them over the top
charging into the teeth of the enemy
this is a
i'll get asked a lot about you know how
do you bring a team together it's like
you got to do hard things together
so it's one thing that's cool about the
ftx program that we run it's
it's challenging
it is mentally challenging there's
actually almost no physical challenge so
that's not what i'm talking about it is
mentally challenging
and you will
you will get put in situations where you
have to make very tough decisions under
pressure
and when you get to do it yourself and
then you watch someone else do it and
they do a call or a bad call or a good
call
it does definitely help out unit
cohesion
i always
thought or kind of
came to the conclusion or whatever that
uh
we get close somebody is to do hard
things like basically you have to go
through the whole spectrum of things
right hard easy
good and bad and you go through all that
together and still emerge without
breaking up or or not being friends or
whatever so a lot of times if you you're
forced in a situation with this
uh what do you call when the interest is
the same for everybody a lot like
aligned interest or the or common
interests
they're kind of forced to be in the
environment so they go through the hard
times
the fun times they go through the whole
spectrum of things and a lot of times in
the military in battle they go through
the really really hard times
and then which kind of you know on the
flip side can precipitate really really
good times as well you know when you
when you're triumphant with the guy with
um next you
in hard times that's a really really
good time so if you have that
consistently yeah boom that bond and
same thing with like
it's funny when you when you started
talking about good times i was kind of
echoes being stupid
but then i thought about it it's like oh
no that's important like just hard times
cool you're gonna forge one part of
unity but also like having fun and
having good times is also a way that
forms a certain part of the unity yeah i
think that a
a group that only has good times you
don't get tested yes you got to go
through some hard too yeah 100 and
that's what it always felt like where
you got to go through the whole spectrum
of ups and downs kind of together over
over a period of time even if you don't
go through it over a period of time if
you get the whole spectrum you'll have a
closeness that's kind of hard to
replicate you know but if you do it
consistently like for a long time
yeah you'd be that's why brother and
sister a lot of time or like
two brothers who grew up together like
really close or whatever um that's why
it's like oh there's a dif that's a
different kind of relationship because
it kind of like me and my brother were
our twins so we literally went through
everything together literally yeah
so like the first time of the whatever
experience the first time was the first
time for both of us you know so like
thompson died and we wound up being
really really close
but that was kind of like that's where
i'd always feel like you know you i can
go through an experience
by myself
and then
a thought that's going to be really
close in my mind like
it'll it won't be a lot of time will go
by before i think oh i wonder what
he would think about this or i know what
he would think about this you know or
you know it like this boom you know like
and you get those kind of thoughts with
the people that you're super close with
yeah and the the harder the combat
the tighter the bond
because also to your point the harder
the combat the better the times are when
you're not in combat anymore yeah and
you kind of bro you kind of stretch out
that spectrum right so it's like more
it's deeper
check
this is an important thing that we've
covered on this podcast before this is a
quick quote
four brave men who do not know each
other well will not dare attack a lion
four less brave but knowing each other
well sure of their reliability and
consequently of mutual aid will attack
resolutely
there is there is the science of
organizations of army of armies in a
nutshell and
that's from battle studies by
ardent the peak who we covered on this
podcast battle studies but that's such a
unimportant thing remember he's like
that's that's that's the science of
building an army
working together
that's why at echelon front we talk
about building relationships because if
we have a relationship if i have a
relationship with three other people
we'll take down a lion
if i don't know these dudes
we're not
i'm not stepping forth it's not
happening you ever watched the movie
speed
speed speed speeds
or something i never watched it okay so
it's really dumb so there's a part at
the end where they like kind of i don't
know fall in love for lack of a better
way to put it and they even say can you
edit that out for this podcast i don't
like talking about that
what love
[Music]
anyway
they they say uh
i think they even mentioned it earlier
where you shouldn't get into a
relationship based on extreme
experiences oh because it's like
whatever the reason or whatever but that
goes with kind of what you're saying
because when you go through these crazy
experiences it brings you closer
together that's like the like like chaz
in the wedding singer when he starts
going to funerals to pick up girls
oh yeah that's senator no no the wedding
crashers
he says uh grief is the nature's most
powerful aphrodisiac
there you go he's extremely jewish these
extreme situations
um
tradition
marine values and attitudes are stressed
from the day the first day the marine
corps
and are constantly reinforced we are
told over and over again a marine never
quits a marine never surrenders a marine
never retreats marines never leave the
dead wounded these values become
ingrained into the very being of every
marine
from the last parallel corporal martin
russ usmc the average marine if such a
condition exists
is definitely not the lad represented on
the recruiting poster
more likely he is a small pimple-faced
young man who
because it has been so skillfully
pounded into him in boot camp believes
he can lick the world
commitment
there's a quote in here about commitment
men take a kind of hard pride in
belonging to a famous outfit even when
doing so exposes them to exceptional
danger
this is an essential element in the
psychology of shock troops
it talks about aggression compassion for
the enemy and non-combatants is a
characteristic that is not uncommon
among marines in the battlefield however
you must recognize that an aggressive
fighting style is our trademark seek to
maintain this determination and
initiative as long as necessary to
accomplish the mission and overcome the
enemy
understand that you will bolster the
confidence of your marines by
accomplishing the mission at the lowest
possible cost in casualties
patriotism every marine must be
convinced of the right brightness of
their country's cause
rewards and punishment the purpose of
our system of rewards and combat is
intended to reflect the recognition of
marines as warriors this recognition of
heroic efforts and sacrifices on behalf
of your fellow marines is an important
leadership responsibility
when it comes to combat
there is no amount of pay or any medal
that can adequately award any marine for
risking their life to achieve a
particular objective
when marines who have experienced combat
are questioned they tend to respond that
their greatest fear
was being perceived as less than
adequate in the eyes of their fellow
marines their only reward
was the respect praise and recognition
which came from within their unit
that is uh no doubt
i've talked many times about what
reputation means
in the seal teams
and that's where you get that reputation
how do you behave
in tough situations in combat situations
even in tough training situations
social factors affecting marines
primary group which is their fire team
squad or platoon are significant aspects
of achieving combat motivation
marines will often identify with friends
who are from their same home state or
same geographical area
this helps build unit cohesion
so getting the guys to work together
this section
discipline esprit de corps and
proficiency are significant factors that
you as a leader can develop in your
marines
these along with morale and motivation
will influence your success in combat
man when you're skilled at something and
you practice and you train it just helps
in every
aspect proficiency is so important and
obviously discipline
and i said earlier that we're going to
get into a little bit of this discipline
is the willful obedience of orders
discipline is exemplified by a situation
where the individual has been taught to
sacrifice their interest for the common
good and respond from a sense of duty
which is more important than individual
rights or wants now
what you and i talk about a lot in here
the common good this is you know
discipline like self-discipline is when
you're gonna do something that's good
not for you right now not the donut not
the sleeping in but what's good for the
common good
that takes discipline
when the moment comes for a leader to
send a marine into harm's way there's
not room for discussion discipline
ensures prompt accomplishment of
assigned missions and spawns initiative
which guides your marines actions in the
absence of order
morale and motivation provide the
foundation for discipline more than
being a simple mechanism for maintaining
order discipline is the essential
condition within a unit that allows to
overcome the extreme fear and fatigue of
combat
and this is why this is the part that i
wanted to get into
uh the three types of discipline
first off is self-discipline
self-discipline is the most important
quality to develop in your marine
self-discipline means that the
individual has a sense of personal duty
to their unit fellow marines and nation
this type of discipline will hold your
marines sturdy against anything the
enemy may throw at them because they
have
a firm inner conviction that they will
not let their fellow marines down
that's what we want that's the most
important quality to developing marine
is self-discipline then it goes to unit
discipline unit discipline is the
behavior that results from the
expectations of marines in your squad it
arises from a form of peer pressure
where a marine knows that for an
individual to belong one must uphold the
standard
this quality of discipline will hold the
marine steady while in the company of
other fellow
marines and then it gets to this and
this is why i wanted to cover this
imposed discipline
imposed discipline is probably the most
important part of this book
imposed discipline is behavior that is
motivated primarily by your immediate
supervision
do it because i said so
it is a direct order to perform now
you've heard me say this many times
we don't want imposed discipline and we
definitely want to impose things on
people but here's the marine corps
saying you know hey
do it because i said so and then they
continue
this discipline influences your marines
to accomplish unpleasant or inconvenient
tasks
and then it says this under extreme
combat conditions
you may be required to resort to imposed
discipline
it says the words required to resort to
it this is not what we want to be doing
yeah
and by the way it's under extreme combat
conditions
so if you're working
in a finance company or you're working
on a construction site or you're working
on a manufacturing line and you think as
a leader you better use imposed
discipline
you're probably wrong
and then it gives the example this was
the only way that captain barrel was
able to force the necessary actions on
the ridge in korea that we referred to
in the unit study
imposed discipline lacks the permanence
of unit discipline and the special
strength of self-discipline so imposed
discipline is like a last resort in
extreme situations
your marines demonstrate discipline
through initiative self-reliance
self-control and obedience
the marine corps style of warfare
requires intelligent leaders with a
penchant for boldness and initiative
down to the lowest level it is the
marines duty to take initiative as the
situation depends demands i like the
fact that they start off by talking
about initiative
because that's what discipline you have
to act or not act but it's what you
personally do it's your own personal
initiative
it talks about self-reliance talks about
self-control
obedience
self-reliance and self-control pretty
straightforward
obedience is when your marine responds
without question when all of your
marines respond to your orders as a team
a sense of unit is unit is created
whereby everyone recognizes that their
role is to contribute to something more
important than one any one individual an
unorganized mob of marines is useless in
a crisis
the strength to overcome the extreme
crisis of combat is greatly affected by
your squad's ability to respond as a
team a squad is capable of dealing with
the chaos of combat only in so far as
the individual marines actions are part
of the total squad effort
we
obedience
right this is this is
i'm surprised they didn't go a little
bit more into
you know these situations where you're
an extreme scenarios
because
otherwise
obedience
is what is occurring
not because you have given direction but
because everyone knows what we're trying
to accomplish
that that that's how a good unit should
work a good unit should work we get into
an enemy contact and everyone knows what
to do not because they're obeying but
because they know what to do they know
why it's important
when you're at a company
and you've got to keep quality up on
your manufacturing line
people
are not going to do it because you told
them to do it and they are obedient
that's why it's happening no they've got
to understand that
the quality of the product is what
supports the reputation of the companies
which is why
people are buying the product which is
why we get to make the product which is
why the product is selling which is why
i have a job when they understand all
those things you don't need to tell them
what to do they're doing it they get it
so that's the kind of
obedience that we want not obedience
that's coming from an external but
obedience because we understand what the
mission is
i think that's an important
facet there that didn't really come out
in their explanation
got a little section on the spree decor
the unit spirit and character the group
not the individual this is us working
together
some indicators
expressions from marines that show
enthusiasm and pride for the unit good
unit reputation among other units
strong competitive spirit willingness to
participate by the members in unit
activities pride in the history and
traditions of the unit those are all
good things here are some ways to
improve this esprit de corps
be the symbol of fighting spirit you
want to develop
start
new people off right by ensuring them
their welcome into and reception by the
unit
train your marines as a team develop the
feeling that the company
as a team must succeed
instruct them in history and traditions
this is something i explain a lot to
companies you got to explain
what's happening where you've been what
you've achieved
use appropriate proper
ceremonies slogans and symbols
use competition wisely to develop a team
try to win in every competition
use decorations and awards properly
it says this make your marines feel they
are invincible that no power can defeat
them and that the success of corps and
country depends on them and the victory
of their unit
now we gotta be careful cause we gotta
watch out for arrogance
right
invincible's a strong word
invincible is definitely a strong word
proficiency
this i i mentioned this is so powerful
because i think it helps your confidence
so much proficiency is advanced in
knowledge and skill
the example they give here is
once again from the book battle
leadership by captain von schell in
peace we should do everything possible
to prepare the minds of our soldiers to
s for the strain of battle we must
repeatedly warn them that war brings
with its surprise and tremendously deep
impressions we must prepare them for the
fact that each minute of battle brings
with it a new assault on nerves as
soldiers of the future we should strive
to realize that we will be faced in war
with many new and difficult impressions
dangers that are thus foreseen
and already
half overcome
let's say that again dangers that are
foreseen are already half overcome if
you know what's coming man you're
already halfway there
in preparing for combat of course
[Music]
they go through a section what do you
need to know
friendly capabilities enemy capabilities
the face of combat
and mental and physical fitness
this is
straight sun tzu right
know your enemy know yourself
friendly capabilities this is not
limited to knowing yourself and your job
this includes knowing your marines
equipment and weapons
know the techniques of combat
and the tactics that are used by a unit
of your size you gotta know the same
thing about the enemy enemies
capabilities their weapons their troops
their equipment
the face of combat
says the goal of this course is to help
you understand the battlefield
environment although that is not
possible to realistically recreate the
battlefield in training you and your
squad should learn as much as possible
about the actual conditions of
combat
during training
you know this is something i wrote about
this in
i can't remember if i wrote about it in
leadership strategy and tactics or in
the forward to about face but
about how i knew when there was no war i
knew there was like a gap that i was
missing i knew there was something i
didn't understand
you know the big the big mish
there was some element and i just tried
to read to try and understand it
so i could figure out
what i was looking at what i was what i
was in for
building and maintaining morale and
motivation in combat
belief
in the mission is the source of morale
and motivation that's why in extreme
ownership we
wrote a chapter called believe you gotta
believe in what you're doing
you've got to believe in what you're
doing developing this beliefs not only
involves developing your squad's
confidence that the job must and will be
accomplished it also involves a deeper
understanding that their individual
sacrifices
and efforts are necessary and irrelevant
what do you got to do instill confidence
leadership from the front is
particularly effective your marines will
always respond when they see that you
are willing to take the same risks as
them
make sure you're assigning people to the
right jobs
make sure they get rest food quarters
remember four hours a night you know we
got to keep that
going and it says here aside from
providing food rest and quarters you
must also be concerned with attention to
duty
you must check to see that positions and
weapons are properly located equipment
and weapons are maintained and that you
attend to the numerous other details
that make an effective combat unit this
requires that you have discipline and
develop a habit of training and
critiquing so that lessons learned do
not have to be relearned
maintaining
morale and motivation
know your marines
who's married who has kids how many
siblings they have what special
circumstances are they under
provide a break in routine this is sort
of attached to what i was saying earlier
but i like this example when possible
provide an opportunity for relaxation
and recreation at kantian in 1967 during
a prolonged period under artillery enemy
fire
one unit
held a tobacco spitting contest judging
accuracy and range
everyone participated in some humorous
situations resulted
so that's a good one
isn't tobacco have you ever seen tobacco
there's like actual tobacco competitions
have you ever seen oh no i have not yeah
what do you do spit yeah
that that right what they just said uh
accuracy and range like they'd i
remember that i remember this accuracy
that there there's like little
techniques to do it though so one like
there's a what they call split finger
technique where like you do something
yeah it was kind of gross but i remember
that being a thing
check
there's a section here
and it's this is again how to maintain
morale motivation this is probably one
of the most important things
include subordinates in the decision
making process whenever possible again
leif and i wrote about this
you never have all the answers and some
of your marines may have good ideas
listening to your marines is not
required to use their ideas
but it will improve their morale
to know that you are willing to listen
to them and by the way they're going to
listen to you more
they're going to listen to you more
maintaining discipline
crucial elements health check the
physical condition of your marines foot
inspections changes in clothing
hygiene enforcement
overall personal cleanliness must be
continuous proper care for cuts blisters
minor wounds rashes and other conditions
directly reflect a unit's level of
discipline a unit's health discipline or
lack of will affect its ability to fight
man check on your people
make sure the weapons and gear is
maintained appropriately
make sure that people are staying in the
game make sure they're keeping their
helmets on and their their weapon close
at hand all that stuff
that's all important for discipline
just like treating people with respect
maintaining that military courtesy
rehashes on that combat may not require
spit and polish but it does not remove
you from the obligation
that you have toward your seniors
discipline is what separates your squad
from a mob of armed civilians
like that
gotta like that
and building esprit de corps
marines are competitors
whatever the event or sport they like to
be challenged and they like to win
if you engage your marines in
competition against another unit your
marines will band together to overcome
the challenge which will build a spree
decor that's so good to have
competitions
whatever you're doing you got a sales
team let's get some sale teams competing
you've got competition on your
manufacturing line
but you can have the most squared-away
workspace in the office
let's see you can have the most
squared-away job site at the
construction company
let's judge it
high standards come from teaching your
marines and then consistently correcting
them it's a bit strong
when i read that like dude you don't
want to be constantly correcting
everyone
i guess it says consistently consistent
credit even that i'm gonna back off a
little bit i'm gonna focus on what
matters but i'm gonna pay attention if
there's some slack happening i'm not
gonna let it get out of control but
don't don't expend a ton of leadership
capital
on that
don't don't let that happen
foster team thinking as a leader your
squad consists of three fire teams each
with its own personality and capability
during platoon squad training have your
fire teams compete against one another
let the losing fire teams do the winners
cleanup like those are the kind of
things
good to go
it talks about
um
when you train train for the conditions
of combat
this is something that's important is
the way you do the way you
train impacts everything that you do
and and you'll you'll mimic what you do
in training with everything that you do
so
for instance we we had rules when i was
running trade
like as soon as we rolled out of the
gate one of these platoons rolled out of
the gate it was a tactical mission
and so there was no like oh hold on a
second we you know we got a flat tire no
it's like you got a flat tire you're
changing that thing it's tactical
you get some word to pass do it
tactically
there's a
vehicle gets stuck hey hold on we got no
no
it's freaking tactical
so
that's how you keep that and even like a
resupply oh we need more water we just
don't walk up to the freaking water
buffalo and start filling our canteens
no you figure out a place to respond you
set up a response
when you say it's tactical like what
it's not
like a nonchalant scenario kind of thing
like kind of like it's
you stay disciplined with the weight
discipline stay just there's all kinds
of opportunities when you're doing that
type of training
to just
to just like okay well
kind of go admin i understand matter of
fact we used to say that hey don't go
admin right now yeah yeah it's almost
like you're pausing the actual training
yeah but you're saying no this is still
part of the training the training is
still on and you know what
the trade act guys my guys influenced
that
so if my guys were coking and joking
it would it would immediately well not
immediately in a lot of cases it would
transfer over to the platoon
so if you got your if your trade at guys
are like shooting the
because we're not part of the platoon
that's supposed to being tactical
it it like spreads yeah yeah i can see
so we would all act like we would be
tactical yeah
there's so many
right of idle
moment of memory because jp and i were
out on an ftx and in the ftx we do at
salonfront we use
this high speed laser tag system which
is really cool
but in trade at a lot of time we use
paintball or simunition which is
shooting paint rounds
and so one of the things that you could
do as an instructor is
as
up like let's say a platoon's walking
down the street or they're walking down
a hallway and i was grading them or
watching them
i would go up and sort of like cover my
face and kind of crouch down as if i was
about to get shot with paintballs
and you'd see like the the platoons
would get so hyped like you could see
they're just instantly going to full
alert mode
because they think they're about about
to get shot that's yeah we'd have like
i'd have like a little like uh put my
hand up over my face
just to kind of hide from the impact of
this ammunition and you do that when
like the training is not going on kind
of a thing or when would you do that
let's say a platoon is walking down a
hallway during the training
and they of course there's a thought in
their mind like hey we might get shot at
right now but when they see me covering
up my face and covering up like my groin
with my hand because i don't want to get
shot sure
or as they see jp like holding his face
and putting his hand over his over his
crotch because he didn't want to get
shot when as soon as they see that out
of the corner of their eye they're like
oh it's coming because you know we're a
traitor we know what's coming yeah
you're the instructors you're not okay
oh there's actual like pranks on youtube
i said i don't really condone the pranks
but you can watch them on youtube where
people will do that kind of stuff where
just in public like to people just in
public like they'll
like cover themselves just like like
something might be coming or something
like that yeah and then and watch the
people reaction the exact same way so it
seems like an element of nature there
where yeah of course and then you
it's not just an element of nature or
trade at because you are probably about
to get shot
but that's important as a trainer that
you
you maintain that high level of
professionalism and you can't be coconut
joking when you expect the platoons to
be tactical and you're sitting around
like an idiot
there's an example in here from
chesty puller from the book marine which
we covered on the podcast bad news only
increased the tempo of polar's training
he cornered colonel pedro de ball
the great gunner who commanded the 11th
marines he said colonel you'll be
starting artillery training next week i
want you to let me know when you'll fire
i want to get my troops under it as
often as i can every day afterward the
men of 107 were in the field and the
11th marines were firing shells streamed
overhead until the whoosh of flying
metal became as familiar as rifle fire
there were many bursts nearby but no
accidents polar was the only battalion
with such training he's just taking his
guys out getting him conditioned
to
well to
freaking bombs going over your head
so good stuff and the last little
section here that just talks about
fitness
physical and mental fitness combat is
physically grueling the demands made on
your squat are going to be extreme and
vary with the environment in which you
are operating routine physical training
in camp lejeune or camp pendleton is not
going to prepare your marines for the
oppressive heat and humidity of okinawa
or the extreme cold for norwegian winter
demanding but creative combat oriented
physical training will serve as a better
way of getting your squad into shape
and then it says mental fitness
map exercises tactical exercises without
troops and professional reading all help
to prepare you and your marines for
decision making in combat
these forms of training are not
exclusive to officers and senior ncos
their way of practicing war fighting
intelligently without having to bring
your entire squad into the field
and you do get better at decision making
you do i would got to see that all the
time and trade it and i still get to see
it with with leaders that we work with
at salonfront they get better at taking
a step back they get better at detaching
they get better at analyzing things
and they get better
so
that and also that mental
and physical fitness
that we're talking about is not just for
you as an individual it's for your teams
that's what it's for and if you're a
leader
you're responsible for your teams and
that means
whether you're working
in business whether you're working in
the military whether you're a first
responder or whether
you are a mom or a dad because you got a
family and you're responsible for the
physical and mental fitness of your
troops
so there you go
and i think this manual reinforces the
fact that combat is like life and it's
like life is just amplified and
intensified because obviously there's
more at stake
but the the lessons apply the discipline
the mental and physical fitness
telling the truth so we're not getting
rumors leading from the front
confronting your fears supporting other
people having discipline
not imposing discipline on your team
asking your team questions letting them
come up with a plan all these things are
in here
universe universal
lessons
for being a better combat leader and
really universal lessons for being a
better
human being
speaking of which echo channels we're
trying to be better human beings across
the board yes we are
we're on the path on the program that's
what we are
the i don't like saying on the program
that as much because it indicates that
like it's kind of this unique like
you're on the program versus you're off
the program like you know like you don't
necessarily have to be on the program
the whole time the path is just a way
it's the way
so we're all on the path we're working
out reading we're listening
listening more than we're talking
hopefully generally we hope so yes we
hope so um through that path you will
need supplementation or it'll put it
this way it'll benefit you a lot you'll
be you'll be that much better off on
this path because it's not always easy
trust me i know
so yes so let's start with energy drinks
if you're into energy drinks got good
news got a healthy energy drinks called
discipline go by speaking of unique
that's a unique thing by the way yeah a
healthy energy drink doesn't exist
except right here there you go yep true
story there's other people are like oh
ours is healthy but we put 350
milligrams of caffeine into it yeah it's
not healthy you can't call that healthy
can't put a label on it calls it healthy
that's a lot you can't put sugar in
there and say it's healthy you can't put
chemicals in there and call it healthy
that doesn't work that's not the truth i
think yeah fully so we have something
legitimately healthy
good to go
yes sir
yep discipline go boom many flavors
eight of them if i'm not mistaken
i think mango is the best one
seems to be uh seems to be what the
robots like as well that's you know many
many entities like the mango it's a good
one you know but hey choose for yourself
but the good news is there's options
what i'm saying as far as flavors go um
again a healthy one there's no real
energy drink out there like it and you
look you can have an energy drink
boom get the upside yep also discipline
go is also a pre-workout there's a
pre-workout form okay for the last few
days i drink coffee i want coffee am i
addicted to coffee i don't think so how
many cups a day
one every day two like two okay two
every day maybe three but it's all at
once it's like in the morning okay
whatever yeah it's like a big coffee
whatever i'd say almost every day but if
i don't have it i'll get a headache or
nothing like that so i don't know that
i'm addicted to coffee okay so what's up
with that pre-workout so for the past
three days i have no coffee
but i worked out first thing in the
morning
actually more than three days okay yeah
more than three days um but i work hard
in the morning so i'm not gonna drink a
coffee then do the pre-workout you know
it's like
it's kind of double what do you call
double dipping unnecessary you're going
straight to the pre-workout straight to
the pre-workout one scoop and a half by
the way okay
i don't get the weird nut here's the
thing the jitter of the coffee and it's
not really a jitter for me anymore it's
more of just a little buzz kind of a
thing i do you don't get that from the
pre-workout i don't even mind the jitter
by the way that buzz or what i don't
mind that but i did notice that you
don't get it but i'll tell you what you
do get
a kick-ass workout
so you don't even need the coffee you
see i'm saying yeah
so anyway yeah so you can use it as a
pre-workout again it's a powder it's
good tastes just as good mix it with
whatever you want water whatever oh but
very good this will help you on the path
when you're working out
trust me you want to be that much more
better off when you're on it trust me um
also
we got some protein this high quality
protein is that right yes sir
it tastes very very good if that means
anything to you if you want to choke
down low quality protein that tastes
kind of junk
this is not the one for you but this one
is good yeah you're going to want that
gratification of just eating something
that tastes delish you know the
you ever seen the meme or whatever it is
that's like oh yeah you can eat
whatever whatever and it's like oh that
face you make one now i want something
sweet right i haven't seen that meme
this isn't me and there's funny ways of
presenting it but it comes all different
forms or whatever
um but it always reminds me of that you
know it's essentially usually someone
who's like
let's say they over consume will say
that and you know i'm super full but now
i want something sweet kind of a thing
like that's a thing or whatever well it
seems to be a thing for me because i'd
be drinking monk i didn't have to have
even after i have a straight up tomahawk
steak
i think that's why it's a mean is a you
know
i'd say it's true
more i would say
65 percent of the time
when i get done eating something that is
like
a steak
i still want to have a little bit of a
little dessert i'm gonna have a little
mulk i'm getting on the mold chain do
you drink milk just in general like oh
i'll just have a cup of milk gossip milk
it's gonna have milk in it because why
would i even that's like just the one of
the dumbest things i've ever heard no
but you know like okay so i'll tell you
this i guess if i was gonna if i was
gonna let's say we had a little scenario
happening where i was gonna have a
chocolate chip cookie right yes sir uh
then
milk with no milk would be in play
but you know how some people drink milk
with dinner that's the norm i had a
keto peanut butter and chocolate cake
the other day
pretty amazing
uh
very shockingly amazing but i also had a
little bit of milk milk regular milk
because it was that was kind of that was
what i was feeling yeah but the keto
chocolate peanut butter cake
credit was given
trying to be
what's the purpose of keto
chocolate peanut butter cake because
then you're not
there's there's two things look i could
tell you that
hey you know you want to stay in ketosis
and all this stuff
i wasn't even in ketosis
when i did that right
but here's the thing
when if you if right now if you and i
sat down and ate a piece of like
whatever just giant chocolate cake
filled with sugar
i would feel like crap would you feel
like crap maybe in two hours
yes i would feel i would feel like crap
in like two hours a big i am whatever uh
what's the word
lethargic lethargic yeah yeah
or maybe even like yeah it probably
doesn't even take an hour immediately
yeah not immediately but you're like oh
i just doused my system with freaking
sugar
and you feel like crap
when you
when i had this and i've had several
keto-ish
desserts yeah right yeah
and
they're good and then you go i still
feel pretty freaking good you know okay
so that's why i understand yeah i'd
rather have that and i'm telling you
they're
they're kind of like milk you know you
can have a mulch like it's a milkshake
you can have one of these and you're not
like i still really want a real
peanut butter freaking chocolate cake or
whatever yeah you know
yeah
um yes certain things don't pair well
though with like chocolate cake or keto
chocolate peanut butter cake or whatever
like like it's too much chocolate like
let's say milk didn't exist right you
you eat a chocolate chip cookie
you drink some white milk yeah you don't
want chocolate milk no it's too much it
doesn't pair well exactly right you're
parents i pair some stuff every once
more like but here's the thing my
pairing is kind of off when i eat chili
you know like chili
chili and rice maybe some cornbread
if we're lucky um i like milk with chili
is that that's weird right
like that's the jam seems like a good
call i think it's a good call yeah for
sure when i was a kid my mom would make
spaghetti
and i would just sit there
at the table like the rest of the family
would be done you'd go on for an hour
and i'd be sitting there just eating
spaghetti
and i would have a gallon of milk and
just pour in glasses of milk and just
pound okay so that's exactly the time
frame when you're i don't know 14 13 14
15 16 your stomach is literally a
bottomless pit you cannot eat enough
my mom said i used to be like asleep in
the car
when i was
like 12 or 13
and just wake up and be like can we get
food right now and my mom said if i
didn't if we didn't get over to a mickey
d's
stat yeah then i'd start getting angry
i understand fully and that is a thing
that's weird that and you
i never thought about that specifically
but i do remember where like okay so i
have this cousin evan edmund charles by
the way
um
e-b-a-n e-b-o-n if i'm mistaken
i forget how to spell it nonetheless
evan um he so he came to visit and we're
the same age so he was but or he maybe a
year older than us i forget so i think
same age and where i remember because
we're in like sixth or seventh grade but
he was huge he's huge like tall dude
super tall and he would drink a whole
half gallon of juice you know the cafe
the whole thing you just drink it i was
like bro like i can understand like that
that juice is delicious and i said but
man i'm not like i'm not ready for that
that's a lot of juice to drink just in
one go like that
and that's a lot
two years later i remember drinking a
whole half gallon of juice because you
were in the zone yeah well because i
grew up to you know i don't think i was
even his size but i was like at that
time i was like yeah maybe 14 15 years
old
so i drink the whole thing and i
remember thinking oh yeah evan was
pounding this juice the same way but i
get it now bro when you're thirsty you
just want to pound that juice
but yes
and yes i am thinking your stomach is
kind of like a bottomless pit you eat
the whole thing a cereal whole thing you
know whole thing like it's nothing
chocolate's already just pounding milk
yeah whole foods yeah i don't know
nonetheless
put milk in the milk whatever yeah and
there's a good a lot of cool little
recipes you can add to the flavors if
you want it's not necessary totally not
sir but if you want you can you can
enhance that milk if you like
um also for your immunity and for things
that you don't want to want to worry
about try workout tray lift weights if
you're into lifting weights
which you should be i think you should
be as
doctors think you should be
i from what i'm understanding more and
more uh resistance training and weights
in my opinion the best form of
resistance training is the healthiest
thing you can do for you barring like
ailments you got heart think situations
all this stuff and of course
cardiovascular has a lot of health
benefits but as far as like immunity uh
balance of hormones uh cognitive like
all these benefits resistance training
from what i understand has proven to be
lifting right we're lifting if you're
lifting heavy
and you're let's say your joint
let's say your joints
aren't all that we'll say or they're
bothering you whatever your body will
not let you lift heavy it'll try to be
like hey let's not live heavy
yep yes it's it's bad it is it's bad and
it's your body telling you that and it's
your body actually saying hey look we
wish you could but you can't yeah it's
kind of like is your body going hey
you're old now just forget about it just
give up d-o-r yeah maybe not the dor but
but kind of along those lines you see
i'm saying let's say the morale of your
body tends to lower and lower when your
joints
oh unity all this stuff
um and it's a natural dude i surfed
yesterday my shoulders were uh it's
weird they were just sore not like uh
injured or anything like this but like
that motion and i'm not so much i've
been surfing like every day for a couple
maybe like a week
and my shoulders are tired sore but not
sore
injured like oh i can't paddle
you know so it's
there you go and those soldiers got some
miles on them man
and we're just joint warfared up i
understand yes
so for these ailments joint warfare
super krill that'll keep everything in
the game and then the there's the
vitamin d3 and the cold war that'll keep
your immunity in the game which you need
by the way i don't know if you knew that
yeah strong immunity strong strong life
man boom hundred percent
boom but yeah both yeah you can get this
stuff by the way you get this stuff at
jugglefuel.com
you can get this stuff you get the
drinks at wawa
we got some other convenience stores
coming online pretty quick we're already
in a bunch more but
i'll actually put together a list of
those so yes wawa you can get all the
stuff at vitamin shop as well go in
there if you want to try something out
there you go
if you subscribe
to any of this stuff which i recommend
then you can subscribe on jockofield.com
and you'll get shipping for free
because look let's face it we're
competing with big there's a big company
around i've heard of that's shipping
stuff for free even though they charge
you money kind of yeah they do actually
not kind of they do charge you yeah yeah
how the membership so free shipping what
does that really mean it means i paid
you money and your shipping was that
free prepaid shipping who are we
what are we doing
is that where we're at
yeah that's where we're at yes sir it is
so we're not gonna charge you to
subscribe you subscribe and you get free
shipping we're giving you a better deal
than some of those other big companies
it's essentially just a recurring it's
not even like a paid subscription
yeah it's discount subscription
essentially
boom win-win good to go good to go um
also origin usa this is where you can
get your american-made stuff
so
jeans boots
some
athletic gear
durable goods
he's coming out with some good pants bro
he had some um like
what color were they like green like
whatever he he made a post pete or
origin we got all kinds of stuff coming
bruh it said next uh print camo and i
think they're like camo jeans work we've
got stuff coming yeah we are we are
investing look when we say we're gonna
we've been
when we say this is rebuilding america
and rebuilding manufacturing america
does that mean when we make money we go
oh cool we made money let's go uh you
know
buy a freaking
new corvette
right
no we're not buying corvettes no sir
tell you what we're doing we're buying
more factory we're buying more equipment
we're buying more material we're
reinvesting back right back into
this
this mission
so when you get a pair of jeans thank
you because it's going to allow us to
make more genes it's going to allow us
to make we're bringing out a whole line
origin hunt you probably heard me
talking about it on on joe rogan we got
all that is in full swing
full swing getting that stuff designed
getting it we're doing the test various
of the various um layouts that we're
using
so this stuff is coming yep and it's
going to be made in america a hundred
percent that's what we're doing
so we appreciate the support
originusa.com we're we are we meaning
you listen to this right now
it's not just it's not just us at that
company we can't we can't rebuild
manufacturing in america without the
support of you this just will not work
it will not work if you don't believe in
rebuilding america then this thing fails
if you don't believe in bringing
manufacturing back to america this thing
fails
when you support though we're gonna be
unstoppable
and you know what i'm willing to bet
pete's willing to bet
in fact we're betting the farm
we're betting everything
we're betting everything that america
will come together
and and help us
bring manufacturing back to america
and listen we are in an economic war
we are an economic war
with china
this is factually what's going on we are
in an economic war with china
and you
and me and origen we are on the front
lines of the economic war
we are the shock troops
so we appreciate the support
originusa.com
oh yeah some jiu-jitsu stuff on there as
well best skis in the world
literally the best skis in the world and
kind of by far because speaking of
combat you want to be in economic combat
we want to win you also want to win on
the mats of justice
so get yourself a origin ghee
i know there's a lot of them out there
a lot of people if you're gonna look if
you're if you're training jiu jitsu
which you should be if you're not trying
to just start training jiu jitsu and
then get an origin key
represent
otherwise again you're you might be
winning the combat front on the mats but
now you're losing the economic war
against china
think about that like oh cool i'm
winning i can beat i can tap this person
oh but my nation is losing a war against
another communist regime is that where
you're at
origin usa people yep it's true let's do
it let's do it let's go
bring it
also chocolate store it's called jocko
store so you go to jacquelinestore.com
this is where you can get your shirts
hats hoodies
some shorts on there discipline equals
freedom
represent while you're on this path
stand by to get some stand but it gets
good all day good all day also there's a
short locker that's our subscription
service it's a good one
some good designs on there good designs
coming up got a valentine's day design
it's actually dude you got to be kidding
me it is not a valentine's day
it's totally here so i shouldn't even
said valentine's day i shouldn't have
but it does come out of february because
i'm mad about it now there's the color
red on it how about that there's no
harder color red from blood dripping
from a sword
that's classified
nonetheless there's some good designs on
there past and present of course um if
you're a member you can even buy and
you're like hey uh what about the past
designs do you have access to those
because they they come out once a month
and they're kind of gone they're not
gone anymore you do have access once
you're a member you have access to
the past design simpleness i added
benefit and upgrade right on just by
becoming a member there you go subscribe
to this podcast
also don't forget about the unraveling
podcast just recorded another episode
with dc
and
we are also just set some things up so
that we can start doing more of those
and we're also going to do
we're going to start talking about
what's going on in the world a little
bit more timely so when things happen
look we're not going to chase the
24-hour news cycle because i'm not
chasing the 24-hour news cycle because
at least 80 of the 24-hour news cycle is
that doesn't matter but there
is 20 that is strategic that needs to be
talked about that needs to be explored
and so dc and i are going to start
putting that out more often
so be ready for that that's the jockle
unraveling podcast we also have the
ground and podcast we got the warrior
kid podcast we also have jocko
underground jockowunderground.com
again we look
we don't know what's going to happen
with all these platforms there's massive
influence in the tech world
that is that is controlling the platform
that you're listening to this right now
and we don't know what they're gonna do
with it we don't know if they're
inserting uh advertisements
into when we're trying to put out some
word
or we're trying to explain
you know what's what's going on in the
world
so we have
jockwinderground.com if we ever need it
it's there as a contingency if you want
to be there and you want to help us
support then go to jockwanderground.com
it costs 8 18 cents a month
if you can't afford that we still want
to support you so if you can't afford
that email assistance at
jackonground.com and we'll we'll figure
it out but we appreciate your support
there as well we have a youtube channel
on the youtube channel
echo
makes videos and then i usually give him
the key element that makes his videos
good
look they'd be good thanks jock they
would be good
but usually there's one little element
that needs to be
added in there you know and i'm always
here for you that's where you come
assistant director yes sir thank you for
that also the video version of this
podcast by the way if you want to see
what t-shirt echo charles is wearing
yeah then you can do that at any moment
it's true
um yeah so yeah there you go also
psychological warfare which is an album
with jocko on each track telling you how
to get through your moment of weakness
this is an effective tool
it's a digital tool
so yeah you can get that wherever mp3s
are offered
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer making
awesome stuff to hang on your wall got a
bunch of books
final spin leadership strategy and
tactics the code the evaluation of
protocol
disciplinary freedom field manual
way the warrior way the warrior kid one
two three and four get those books for
every kid that you know
you will do so much to enhance their
life and get them moving in the right
direction
mikey and the dragons for the little
kids
about face by hackworth i wrote the
forward on the new version extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership that i wrote with my brother
leif babin who i also have a leadership
consultancy with called echelon front
where leadership is the solution go to
echelonfront.com
if you want us to come and help you with
your company if you want to come to one
of our live events and you can also
check out our online training the
academy
called extremeownership.com
if you
want to learn to take ownership of your
life of your business of your family
of your fitness of your health
then go to extremeownership.com
i'm on there two three times a week live
to interact you want a question for me
just go on there and ask it
extremeownership.com and if you want to
help service members active and retired
their families gold star families check
out mark lee's mom mama lee
she's got an amazing charity
organization and she helps
veterans and their families so much go
to america's
mightywarriors.org if you want to donate
or you want to get involved and if you
want any more of my lame lectures
[Music]
or you need any more of echo's
disorienting declarations
you can find us on the interwebs on the
gram on the facebook on the twitter
on getter
echoes that echo charles i am at jocko
willink and to the army navy air force
and for this manual today especially for
the marine corps thank you for being
leaders doing the toughest job in the
world and that is going into combat
and to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for doing what you do here at
home also an incredibly tough job which
is keeping us safe thank you
and everyone else out there think about
all these factors
not just for leading marines but for
leading yourself
and it says in the book the
self-discipline is the most important
quality it is your personal duty to
yourself
and if you develop this discipline
then like a disciplined marine you will
hold sturdy against anything that's
thrown at you
based on that
firm inner conviction that you will not
falter you will not flounder you will
not fail
and to demonstrate that discipline
to demonstrate that discipline you have
to show self-reliance you have to have
self-control and you have to have
initiative
to make things happen
so take some initiative
go out there and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out